[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEYSER: Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to MIT's 2003rd
commencement exercises
for the year 2003 in
historically Killian Court.
That's not 2003 commencements,
that's the year.
But it's early for me.
In approximately
90 minutes, we'll
be joined by our
guests of honor,
who you'll be able to see
on the big screen over there
to your right.
That's that great big jumbotron.
And you will be able to
watch the commencement
as our guests walk around and
then come up into the court.
We will visit with a few
of them in a few minutes.
But right now, we have
prepared something
to help pass the time
pleasantly for you.
But before we do that,
I have an announcement
that I have to read.
So please bear with me.
I need to inform you of the
following safety procedure.
In the event of a
sudden emergency,
such as a severe
thunderstorm that
would necessitate
evacuation of this Court,
you will hear an announcement.
Emergency exit signs would
be immediately posted,
indicating routes you
should take to leave.
These signs will lead
you to a corridor
where MIT personnel
will further direct
your travel to a safe location.
Now, this is a glorious day.
And that's MIT commencement
speak for "it's not raining."
And it's supposed to get better.
So let us count our blessings.
Welcome to MIT's Killian Court.
This setting is a
very rich one that
plays an important
role in MIT's history,
and I would like to introduce
to you my colleague, Warren
Seamans, MIT Historian and
Former Director of the MIT
Museum, who knows more about
MIT lore than perhaps anyone.
Warren?
SEAMANS: This is the 87th
season for Killian Court.
In 1916, MIT moved from its
home of 55 years in the Copley
Square of Boston's
Back Bay to this site.
And this, since that time,
has been literally the center
of MIT activities.
For the first several years,
graduations were held--
or commencements were
held here in the court.
However, in 1922 the tent that
was housing them blew down.
So henceforth, after that,
for the next approximately 50
years, there were other
sites found for it,
including Symphony
Hall in Boston
and the Rockwell Cage, which
is the large athletic center.
However, about 20 years ago
they moved back to this area,
and so we are here today.
To expound a little bit on
the historic part of this--
this has been the home of
everything from inaugurations
of new presidents to the
ceremonies commemorating
the passing of
former presidents.
It was originally known
as the Great Court,
and it comprised three parts--
Lowell and Dupont
Courts-- because they're
the people who actually
paid for the land
that MIT was built on in 1916.
In 1974, it was renamed the
James Rhyne Killian, Jr. Court,
in honor of James Rhyne
Killian who, at that point,
had been both President
and Chairman of the MIT
Corporation.
It has also served--
this locale has
served as the final
resting place for at least
two presidents whose
ashes have been
spread throughout the Court.
So you are really treading on
some of MIT's most holy ground.
With that, I will
turn back to Jay.
KEYSER: Thank you, Warren.
So Killian Court is kind
of like MIT's Central Park.
All kinds of things go on here--
picnics, research, gatherings
like this.
And to give you a
better idea of that,
we are going to offer a bird's
eye view of this setting
through this video report on
MIT's robo-copter project.
So please, direct your
eyes to the humongous-tron.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This project is to demonstrate
automated acrobatic maneuvering
for an aerial vehicle.
- In the Killian Court, we
have done a flight in so-called
Control Augmentation System,
where the pilot gives very
high-level commands.
For example, go forward
or go sideways or turn,
go slightly higher,
slightly lower.
The pilot doesn't
have to take care
of stabilization of the system.
That's done by automatic
control system.
- The vehicle we
did not work on.
We purchased a vehicle directly
from a miniature aircraft.
- Nice.
- We picked this machine
because it's very cheap.
It's mass manufactured.
And we could outfit it with our
own electronics very quickly.
- This is our ground station.
It's a very old laptop,
about three years old.
It runs a real-time
operating system.
And it gets the data from the
helicopter about the sensors
and the state, [INAUDIBLE]
velocities, altitude,
and everything else.
The ground station
operator monitors
that all of the
sensors are doing fine.
And then we take all this data.
We analyze it, we
record the trajectories
of acrobatic maneuvers the
[INAUDIBLE] has performed.
And we designed the controllers
that follow this trajectory.
- So what happens is we use
filtering technologies in order
to synthesize this information
into a complete and accurate
estimate of where the helicopter
is and what it's doing.
- Previously a small rotocraft
and large rotocraft as well,
when they were
flown autonomously,
have been flying very
non-aggressive trajectories.
And what we have contributed
is autonomous aggressive
Maneuvering.
So we were able to
design the control laws
that allow us to perform an
aerobatic maneuver completely
hands off.
- The applications could
include news gathering,
so gathering video footage
of hard-to-explore areas,
top of mountains, top of
volcanoes, fire situations,
any environment which is very
complicated, very contrived,
and that would require very
agile maneuvers and very agile
machines to operate.
- You can also use it
for a number of military
applications-- for example,
urban surveillance and pursuit.
- There's an aesthetic
component to our research,
which is to make such machines
as graceful as possible.
What we would want is that
this machine eventually
behaves and flies as well,
if not better, than a bird.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEYSER: MIT's mission
statement includes the phrase
"We seek to develop in each
member of the MIT community
the ability and passion to
work wisely, creatively,
and effectively for the
betterment of mankind."
The Nepal Water Project
illustrates this commitment
in action, and we'd like to
show you that on the jumbotron.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The beginning of the Nepal
Water Project was in 1998.
I was invited as a water
expert to a conference
called the Second International
Women on the Water Conference.
There were some 75
Nepali peasant women
who had walked two and three
days from remote parts of Nepal
to attend this conference.
About 70% of people in Nepal
lack access to clean water.
So when a woman goes out and
collects water from the source,
chances are that water
will be contaminated.
Moreover, one in 10
children in Nepal
are dying from
waterborne diseases.
- The most grave or sort
of pressing problems
in the world today,
in my opinion,
is diseases caused by
waterborne pathogens.
So you have the leading cause
of childhood death in Nepal,
for example, and in many other
developing countries is either
from a disease caused
by pathogens in water
or a result of malnutrition.
The systems that
we're all looking at
are point of use water filters,
and the idea behind that
is that it's an interim way--
because larger
distribution systems
won't be accessible
in the near term.
- When I attended this
conference in 1998
and actually met the women
whose lives were impacted
by the water pollution problems
and they looked me in the eye
and I looked them in the eye
and they said, my children are
sick and dying and you
are a water engineer who
knows the answers, tell us
how to solve this problem,
I felt a big
responsibility to come up
with some solutions that
would address that problem.
- Well, the Nepal project
has been a great project.
Susan Murcott has done
this for three years now.
Many of our competing
programs, they only
require students
to take courses.
And we require them to
take courses and also do
a rigorous group project.
[INAUDIBLE]
- When they look for post-grad
studies, graduate studies,
I was specifically looking
for something applied
in the developing countries.
I read on the web that
MIT, and specifically
the Master of Engineering,
was offering this program.
And I specifically
came for this.
- The Nepal Project
is now a good example
for students to come together
with interdisciplinary
backgrounds and work
on a real problem
and at the same time experience
some of the rest of the world
that many students
don't get a chance
to visit and to share that
experience with other students
in the program.
It's a good opportunity
to work on something
that's real world and
important to real people.
- Doing [INAUDIBLE] studies on
water treatment for developing
countries is a
totally new thing,
which I probably would not get
a chance to do anywhere else.
The unique part
about this project
is actually the ability
for every one of us
to get down to the field,
to the project country,
and actually do something and
make a difference to the people
there.
- Choosing a project
to do for my thesis,
I wanted to do something that
would impact people directly
and to help them.
And the water and sanitation
projects that Susan
proposed all fit this bill.
Arsenic was found
by an MEng student
about two years ago
in Nepal, and they
suspected that there
would be arsenic
in Nepal because there's high
arsenic in West Bengal, India,
and in Bangladesh.
Arsenic is naturally occurring
in the ground water there.
And this year we're
tackling three technologies,
and I'm doing an
iron-coated sand
technology that
will remove arsenic
when the water is passed by.
- My arsenic filter
works excellent.
It removes 100% of
all the arsenic,
and I was really impressed.
And I also did some
arsenic species and tests.
And I visited over 50 different
wells and took samples,
and it was personally
very successful.
- Even though MIT
is famous as being
the pinnacle of high
technology, it's
also a pinnacle of
entrepreneurial and creativity
and innovation and
problem solving.
And we are using the
best and brightest
to focus their attention on
one of the biggest problems.
I think of it as being
something like an Outward Bound
expedition for these kids,
only on a scientific level.
- That is one of the very
important reasons why
I choose this program
instead of the other offer
that I got from
other universities,
is I have the chance to
work in a developing country
and actually do something good.
This kind of
program can actually
help to promote women's
role in society,
because they trained women
to be the well mechanics.
So when they gain
this kind of position,
they can gain more
respect from the society.
- I think this project
really is my MIT experience.
I think that course work and
the other things I'm doing,
it helps with this
project, but I
think that this is the
reason I came to the program.
And this project is--
I'm hoping to take as much as
I can away from this project,
and I think that it's really
the centerpiece of my MIT
experience.
- Kids come back from
these experiences changed--
not just changed as scientists,
but changed as human beings.
And I've seen this time and
again, and it's very exciting.
- See-- students from all around
whom are attracted to this
project and interested in these
things is there's a genuine
desire to make a difference, not
through small steps and science
some time off in
the future but now.
You know, these are
pressing problems
that need to be solved now.
- I have this
poster from UNICEF.
It says, "What do you want
to be when you grow up?"
And there's a
picture of a child.
And the answer below is
"alive," exclamation point.
That's basically to tie it
back to the Women in Water
conference-- what
these women were
asking for is, how do I
take care of my children?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEYSER: We're going to
use, through the magic
of technology, we're going to
go over to the Howard Johnson
Athletic Center and interview
one of the students there.
It occurs to me that I didn't
tell you I'm an MIT Professor.
That's why it's important
that you pay attention
to what I say.
Consider this free tuition.
So now we're going to go over
to Howard Johnson's and see
if there's anybody for us.
Hi, can you hear me?
BENIFLAH: I can hear
you loud and clear.
KEYSER: What's your name?
BENIFLAH: Jacob Beniflah.
KEYSER: Jacob, what--
say your name again.
BENIFLAH: Jacob Beniflah.
KEYSER: Uh-huh.
And what school are you in?
BENIFLAH: School of Science.
KEYSER: And you're getting
your degree in what today?
BENIFLAH: Brain and
cognitive science.
KEYSER: Hey, that's what I'm in.
BENIFLAH: Awesome.
KEYSER: Tell me, do
you have family here?
BENIFLAH: Yeah, I
have-- both my parents
have been there since
7:20 in the morning.
KEYSER: Where are they?
Where are Jacob's parents?
Raise your hand, please.
Are they here?
BENIFLAH: They should
be right at the front.
KEYSER: Stand up
and raise your head.
Everybody's standing up.
How many parents
do you have, Jacob/
BENIFLAH: I don't know.
KEYSER: Oh, there they are.
Hi, everybody.
Say hello to them.
BENIFLAH: Hi, Mom and Dad.
How are you doing?
KEYSER: We don't
have a mic on them,
but they say hello
to you, Jacob.
Tell me, Jacob,
where did you live
when you lived here at MIT?
BENIFLAH: I lived at AEPi,
right across the river.
KEYSER: And how did you like it?
BENIFLAH: It was awesome.
Best experience ever.
KEYSER: But during
the winter when
you had to cross the
bridge, wasn't it cold?
BENIFLAH: I'm from Texas,
so I drive everywhere.
KEYSER: [CHUCKLING]
What do you drive?
BENIFLAH: Jeep Grand Cherokee.
KEYSER: I mean,
is it a big Jeep?
BENIFLAH: Yeah.
Heated seats.
It's awesome.
It is the way to
cross the river.
KEYSER: So tell me, Jacob,
have you paid for the car?
BENIFLAH: Uh, my daddy.
KEYSER: Ah, good.
Daddy also paid for
the tuition, right?
BENIFLAH: Yes.
KEYSER: But he's from Texas.
BENIFLAH: Yes, he is.
Originally from Spain, though.
Both my parents are from Spain.
KEYSER: Ah.
Buenas dias.
BENIFLAH: Buenas dias.
KEYSER: [SPANISH].
I just said, I can
speak a little Spanish.
Tell me, Jacob, what are you
going to do when you graduate?
BENIFLAH: I'm going
straight to medical school.
KEYSER: And you're
going to become a--
do you know what medical
school you're going to?
BENIFLAH: UT
Southwestern in Dallas.
KEYSER: And have
you picked what sort
of a medical career you want?
BENIFLAH: I have no clue.
Some kind of doctor.
I don't know.
KEYSER: All right.
Thanks a lot, Jacob.
And I see you have
some friends with you.
BENIFLAH: Yeah.
They want to say hi
to their parents.
Can they?
KEYSER: Yes, of course.
BENIFLAH: All right.
KEYSER: We'll take them all.
Okay, what's your name?
STUDENT: Hi, Mom.
Hi, Dad.
KEYSER: No, that's
not your name.
STUDENT: Oh, I'm
Naomi Schmelzer.
And I'm majoring in Course 9.
KEYSER: Wait a
minute, wait a minute.
These people--
KURNIK: Hi, I'm Rebecca Kurnik.
I'm a biology major.
Hi!
KEYSER: You see, that's
an MIT student for you.
They don't listen
to their professors.
STUDENT: Hi, I'm Stephanie.
I'm majoring in Course 3.
And I just wanted to
say hi to my mom and dad
and the rest of my family.
BERGER: Ah.
Okay, you're Stephanie who?
What?
BENIFLAH: Stephanie Berger.
KEYSER: Where's the Bergers?
Are the Bergers here?
BENIFLAH: Are your parents here?
BERGER: Yes.
BENIFLAH: They should be here.
KEYSER: Raise your hand.
Would the Bergers
raise their hand?
Oh, there you are.
Good.
Now, let's have the--
and who's the other people?
You talked so fast,
I couldn't catch up.
What's your other names?
BENIFLAH: This is
Rebecca Kurnik.
KEYSER: Okay.
Where is your parents?
Where's Rebecca's parents?
BENIFLAH: Rebecca,
are your parents here?
KURNIK: Yeah, they should be.
I told my dad to
get up really early.
KEYSER: So tell me,
Rebecca, where are you
going after you graduate?
KURNIK: I'm also going
to medical school.
I'm going to be
in Boston, though.
I'm going to Tufts.
KEYSER: And what kind of--
KURNIK: I'm excited.
BENIFLAH: What kind of
doctor do you want to be?
KURNIK: I don't know
what I want to be.
We'll see.
Right now I'm just
going to graduate.
KEYSER: Oh, great.
Well, look, I think
it's really interesting
that of the four that we've
talked to, two of them
want to be doctors.
BENIFLAH: Not two, but three.
KEYSER: You mean
there's a third--
KURNIK: Naomi's also
going to medical school.
STUDENT: I'm going to Mt.
Sinai next year for an MD/MPH.
KEYSER: Well, I'll be darned.
Three doctors.
And I was talking to
one of the gentlemen
here in the audience
who tells me that he
lives next door to a hospital.
So there must be a real
affinity between MIT students
and medicine.
BENIFLAH: There definitely is.
There definitely has to be.
KEYSER: All right.
Hey, listen guys,
we'll be seeing you
over here in a minute.
But it's been great
talking to you.
BENIFLAH: Nice
talking to you too.
KEYSER: Nice talking to you.
And we'll see you soon.
KURNIK: Thank you.
KEYSER: Okay.
BENIFLAH: Thanks.
BERGER: Bye.
KEYSER: I feel as if America's
health is in good hands.
I'm interested in learning a
little bit about the audience
here.
For example, is
there anybody here
for whom this is not
your first commencement?
Have you been here
more than once?
If you've been here more than
once, come up here, will you?
If this is your second or third
commencement, come up here.
And I'm also interested in
who came here from the--
who came from the
farthest distance?
I want to see who
wins that prize.
So if you think that you've
come here from the longest
distance-- we're
going to roll a tape,
and while we're rolling the
tape, you guys come up here
and we'll talk.
Okay.
MIT is world-renowned
for its excellence
in science and engineering
education and research.
What is less known
is that MIT also
has a thriving arts program.
Look at the huge-atron
over my shoulder.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- One morning I came up the
steps of Massachusetts Avenue
and walked through the
door, and the entire space
had been transformed
into a wheat field.
Innovative visual arts projects
like that are happening
all the time on campus.
The arts at MIT, like science
and engineering at MIT,
are on the cutting edge
of their disciplines.
They are serving the students--
- And I've got a rap sheet
that's got a list of--
- --and in the way they're
serving the students,
ultimately they're going to
be serving the entire society.
- At MIT, you'll find some
of the best musicians.
Virtuosos-- it could
be the person who
lives next door to
me has perfect pitch,
and if you name any song
whatsoever he can strum it down
out his guitar.
If it has multiple
lines of music,
he can strum out all
lines on his guitar.
And you can see that.
It's indicative of the level
of quality of the MIT Symphony
Orchestra, the MIT
Concert Choir, et cetera.
- Last year I got
to premiere a song
cycle written by
an MIT composer,
and that was a lot of fun.
Modern poetry, modern
music, and everything.
- Everyone at MIT
cares about something,
whether it's their
classes or their UROP
or some student
activity they do,
there's always something
that they really care about.
- The thing about MIT students
that I most appreciate
is the elegance of their
thinking and the fact
that it's sort of live
and let live here.
- [SINGING "BLUE MOON" WITH NON
ENGLISH LYRICS]
- There's a point
of concentration
that any discipline requires,
whether it's engineering
or it's directing or
acting or painting.
That point of concentration
is the focal point.
It is the thing around which
you organize your thinking
and your technique.
And so the fact that there
is ensemble work where people
learn to work
collaboratively is something
that I see that people take
into their labs in a way
that you would hope that
labs work collaboratively.
[MUSIC - SANTANA, "SMOOTH"]
- [LAUGHING]
- I'll kill you!
- Ooh, he kills me!
- Well, right now
it's sort of the--
theatre is a way I can
investigate my own sort
of identity, especially
my own cultural identity.
But I also enjoy theater because
it's such a collaborative art.
And it's a lot like engineering,
which is one of my majors,
and I also intend to
pursue engineering
in that it is so
collaborative, and so you
get a lot of different
people's perspective on things.
- I'm Arning.
I'm the Curator at the MIT
List Visual Art Center.
And I'm here in our annual
Student Loan Exhibition.
MIT, quite usually,
has a collection
of artworks that students
get to live with for a year.
- Arts are in every
new building now.
It's pervasive from
that point of view,
and it's pervasive
from the things
that you see people
doing all over.
My favorite program is
the Council Scholars,
of course, because I'm
very involved with them.
It started with 20 or so
undergraduate students,
and now we have both
undergraduate and graduate
students.
Computer scientists,
they're chemical engineers,
they're architectural
students, and they
are not, with a few exceptions,
actually going out and leading
professional lives as artists.
But this is something that's
been very important to them
all their lives.
- We find our students,
a certain number of them,
go on to graduate study
in music and in the arts.
Some of them go on to become
leaders of arts organizations
within their communities.
Some of them go on to
sing in organizations
or performing organizations like
the Tanglewood Festival Chorus.
And in a couple of
notable situations,
I have myself a
number of times I've
been engaged by organizations
whose presidents were
either in my class
at MIT 20 years ago
or had been at MIT
years before that.
[CHAMBER MUSIC]
My first visit to MIT, when
I walked through the halls,
I remember passing through
the math department
on the way to Building
14, where we used to be.
And I looked in a door and
saw mathematicians hunched
in carrels, and I felt right at
home, because it looked exactly
like walking down the
halls of Juilliard
into the practice rooms
and seeing people working
personally on something.
- One of the amazing
things about MIT students
is the incredible wide range
of interests and abilities
that extends far beyond the
intellectual and the academic.
And our special guest with us
this section of the concert
is no exception to that.
His name is Jonathan Lee.
[APPLAUSE]
[PIANO CONCERTO]
- I think that being involved
in activities like this
only enhances your education.
I think it's
important while you're
at school to focus on things
besides your own research.
- So people come here as
scientists, as engineers,
as mathematicians, but
when they are making art,
they're artists.
- (CHANTING) People moving
out, people moving in.
Why?
Because of the
color of their skin.
Ball of confusion.
- I think that it's
a way of chilling out
some of the stresses you have.
It's a way of looking
at the things you're
doing with a broader picture.
- It's like, anything
you want to do,
MIT students will go off
and form a group for it.
And then they'll actually
carry it through,
because they put all their
engineering skills to work
and they engineer
these art groups.
And there are piles of them.
- Hi.
We're the Chorallaries.
We have our new CD,
which you should buy.
We're the Institute's only coed,
secular, all-MIT, non-jazz,
completing a capella group.
So that makes us special.
And you're all special too.
We're going to sing
another song now.
- (SINGING) We
are the engineers,
we are the engineers,
we are the engineers--
- So you shouldn't
think that MIT
has no art, because
they've got them
sprawling all over the place.
- Well, now the advice I
give to incoming freshmen
consistently is don't
leave your trumpet at home.
You can use it here.
- (SINGING) Engineers.
Go, go, go, go--
engineers.
We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
Engineers.
We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
Engineers.
We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
Engineers.
We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
A lady and an engineer
were sitting at the park.
And the engineer was working
on some research after dark.
Scientific method was--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEYSER: Well, when I
asked if there were people
who had come the
farthest and there
are people who have been to
more than one commencement,
I got a windfall.
All of these people
that you see around me
have something interesting
to say about their experience
with previous
commencements or distance.
Let's do distance first.
This gentleman here and his
wife I think wins the prize.
He's from Malaysia,
and your village is?
AUDIENCE: Malacca.
KEYSER: And you're,
what, 12,000 miles away?
AUDIENCE: It is exactly
halfway around the world.
Because every time
when I phone my son
at 9:00 AM in the morning,
It's 9:00 PM in MIT.
KEYSER: That's great.
But we have some people here
from Texas, Mercedes Valley.
Raise your hands.
And where is the young
woman from Alaska?
Did she go away?
Yeah, there was
somebody from Alaska.
Where else?
Anybody else from an
interesting place?
Oh, Delhi.
Where's Delhi?
Oh, you're from Delhi, yeah.
How far away is that?
AUDIENCE: When it's 11:00 in
the morning over here, it's--
8:00 PM in New Delhi.
KEYSER: So what is
it, it's like 6:00 PM?
It's 6:00 or 7 o'clock
in the morning now--
I mean, in the evening
in New Delhi now.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
KEYSER: Does that
make you homesick?
No?
Are you still
suffering from jet lag?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
I'm too excited to attend
my son's graduation.
My son is graduating from
doing a masters in architecture
and urbanism I'm really
excited about that.
KEYSER: That's wonderful.
Okay, so now we
have somebody here
who has a multi-generational
connection with MIT.
Tell us about that.
AUDIENCE: Well, my
grandfather graduated in 1911.
My father taught at
the MIT Radar School.
KEYSER: What's your name?
AUDIENCE: My name
is Peter Bloomsberg.
I graduated in 1971, and my
son John is graduating today
from mechanical engineering.
KEYSER: Are you related
to the Bloomsberg
in the financial district?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm not.
KEYSER: So I can't
ask for a stock tip
or anything like that.
All right, well, it's been
nice talking to you anyway.
So now, how many
people here, this
is your second commencement?
Let's see the hands.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
Third commencement?
One, two, three.
How about fourth?
One, two three.
Fifth?
OK, fifth.
The fifth?
Come on out here.
You win.
AUDIENCE: I thought you meant
commencement in general.
KEYSER: Oh, a technicality.
You win on a technicality.
I mean, how many times have
you been here in Killian Court
watching the parade?
AUDIENCE: I'm a professor
at Rice University.
I go to commencements
every year.
So I thought you--
KEYSER: Well, you
win that anyway.
All right.
Where's the guy with four?
Come on out here.
So when was the last
time you were here?
CROSS: 1977.
KEYSER: What's your name, sir?
CROSS: I'm John Cross.
KEYSER: And tell
us, have you noticed
anything different between
commencements then and now?
CROSS: It's better to
be on the receiving end.
KEYSER: Well, what about--
say something nice about
how they've improved.
CROSS: Well, they're having
them in Killian Court,
which makes it a
much nicer setting.
KEYSER: Oh they didn't have them
in Kilian when you were here?
CROSS: I think we had it
in the cage way back then.
KEYSER: Well, what about the
other three that you went to?
After '77, then
what did you go to?
CROSS: The first one was '72.
The second one was '76
with my wife's PhD.
She's right over here.
KEYSER: Please come up, ma'am.
What's your name?
CROSS: Virginia Cross.
KEYSER: All right, I want to
show you how her blouse matches
the microphone.
We worked on that.
Okay, so the four are, '72--
CROSS: '72, '76, '77, and '03.
KEYSER: And '03, wow.
Very good.
So who is-- oh yeah, now you.
What are yours?
Tell us yours, sir.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: My name is
[? Raman, ?] and I'm here with
my wife [? Reika. ?] In 1999,
my son Sunil graduated in EECS.
In year 2000, he
got his masters.
And last year, my son
Sanjay got his bachelors,
and this year he's getting
his masters in EECS.
KEYSER: And I'd like to show
you with this close-up shot
how the microphone
matches his wife's blouse.
All right, folks.
Thank you.
Hey, everybody, give
them a big hand, huh?
Thank you very much, folks.
You've all been wonderful.
I'm sorry I didn't get to
all of you, but stick around.
God bless you all.
It's a pleasure.
AUDIENCE: I actually came to
say something interesting.
KEYSER: You know what?
I'm working now.
You can't talk to me.
I'm supposed to be working.
Wait just a second.
For God's sake.
Don't go away.
I'll be right with you.
I've got an interesting
piece of information for you.
I don't know if you know this
or not, but you can tell--
you can tell what the
temperature is outside
if you can hear a cricket.
What you do is you count the
number of chirps in 15 seconds,
add 40, and that's the
temperature outside.
So now what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to give you a little test.
[CHIRPS]
Okay, what's the temperature?
Good.
In the next video,
you're going to learn
about research that
also uses crickets,
but they aren't insects.
The Cricket Indoor
Location System
is an example of a
research initiative
within the School of
Engineering that focuses
on information engineering.
These crickets are
part of Project Oxygen,
a partnership among the
laboratory for computer
science, the Artificial
Intelligence Lab,
and several major
corporations that
seek to make computation
and communication as
abundant and natural to
use as oxygen in the air.
Now let's look at the Cricket
Indoor Location System.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Oxygen is a large project
between the labs, computer
science, and the Artificial
Intelligence Lab at MIT.
And it's trying to
build systems in a world
where computing is plentiful
and communication is pervasive.
So today we have
computers on our desks,
but in the Oxygen
vision, you have
computers everywhere
around us-- in the walls,
in objects and
devices all around us.
And they're all
networked together.
A critical piece of information
that you need is location.
You need to know
where objects are,
you need to know
where devices are,
and you need to know
where users are.
So Cricket is a technology that
provides location information
to users in indoor areas
and in urban areas.
So Cricket is intended for
indoor deployment-- places
like campuses or museums or
shopping malls or subways
or airports, where
GPS doesn't work.
The way Cricket works is there
are devices called beacons.
It has a radio
transmitter on it,
and it has a couple of
other funny-looking things
that are ultrasonic
transmitters.
And what Cricket beacons do
is they transmit information.
They're programmed
with information
about their own location,
and they periodically
transmit this information
in the form of chirps.
Now, you have users
and other devices
in the environment that have an
analogous piece of machinery,
or a little device attached
to them, called listeners.
And what the
listeners are doing is
they're receiving the
information from these chirps,
and they're doing some
calculations and computations
on these listener devices and
determining their location.
You often are asked as a
child how far away a cloud is.
And the way you estimate
that is to first observe
when you see the lightning
and then wait a few seconds
and you hear thunder
a little bit later.
And you use that time
difference to estimate how far
away the cloud is
because sound travels
so much slower than light.
This is the same idea.
Our equivalent of lightning
is the radio frequency message
sent on a wireless channel,
and our equivalent of thunder
is an ultrasonic message.
It's ultrasound.
You can't hear it, but it
travels at the speed of sound.
And we use this time difference
of arrival technique.
We started off doing things like
navigation application, which
automatically
discovers where you
are, downloads maps, and shows
you where you want to go.
You tell it where
you want to go,
and then it gives
you directions.
We've also worked on
entertainment-style
applications, where we
have live television coming
onto handheld devices.
You're watching television
on your handheld computer
and you enter a room
with a bigger screen,
and with a single operation
you can cause that television
stream to seamlessly
migrate to a bigger screen.
We've also done
applications for hospitals
where the idea is to use this
to keep track of patients
and keep track of
medical equipment.
We are now starting to
work with MIT facilities
to deploy sensor
networks, networks
of little tiny sensors
attached with location that
will keep track of smoke
and fire and chemicals
and so forth for safety.
We've also done some
fun applications
like games, where
you're actually
in the real world moving
around, and you see your actions
in the virtual world
of the computer.
People have also talked
about using cricket
in construction
systems, where you
want to keep track of equipment,
lots of which are moving,
and make sure that your
planning of construction
goes according to what
you had envisioned.
So I think it's an
important project
because it's interdisciplinary
and brings together
a lot of different disciplines
within information engineering.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SEAMANS: For those
of you old enough
to remember the popular 1970s
television series The Six
Million Dollar Man
and Bionic Woman,
you may think that some of the
new medical developments we
hear about in the news are
reminiscent of bionics,
those technological
advanced components that
give our bodies superhuman
physical abilities although we
haven't quite reached
that frontier,
we are building the foundation
for a new age of medical,
environmental, and other
societal breakthroughs made
possible by the melding of
modern biology and engineering.
MIT's School of Engineering
is at the forefront
of this new field of
biological engineering.
The next video presents one
example of current research
in its biological engineering
initiative, the Liver Chip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I originally got started in
the field of tissue engineering
by trying to replace developed
methodologies for replacing
organs in people.
So for example, ways to
take a single donor organ
like liver and use
it in 100 patients
so that you could take
cells out and grow them
in little reactors
and transplant them
into the patient.
And then I had an epiphany
about five years ago,
in that right now the
leading cause of transplants
in the Western world
is hepatitis C.
And it's been very difficult to
develop drugs for hepatitis C--
we've known about it
for over 20 years--
because there's no way to
culture the virus in vitro.
So liver cells
lose their ability
to be infected when you
take them out and put them
in culture.
So the epiphany was, maybe
what we should really
be doing is building
physiological models of tissue
so we can understand
disease, because if it's me,
I'd rather have a
cure for the disease
and never get an organ
transplant than ultimately have
some organ grown in my lab.
So if we can head off and
prevent organ transplants,
it will be much
better for the patient
than if we build an organ
to put in them after they
get really, really sick.
So we're developing
a hepatitis model.
That's really the proof
that you have something
that functions as liver.
We still have a ways to go
to demonstrate definitively
that we're getting the kind
of functional responses
that you want to mimic
the in vivo liver.
So we're not all there yet,
but we have every indication
that we're headed very
much in the right direction
compared to other
methods of keeping liver
cells alive outside the body.
What we're doing is using
micro-fabrication technology
to build little
three-dimensional scaffolds
that coax a mixture of cells out
of the liver to reform a liver
tissue and culture.
So in liver, there are
a number of cell types
that form the tissue.
And they're put
together in repeat units
called a capillary bed.
And when the liver
needs more mass--
so let's say you have a little
tumor taken out of the liver,
it will regrow.
It adds a whole bunch
of these capillary beds.
So all we do is try to
rebuild that in culture
by building a scaffold
that causes cells taken out
of the liver to
grow into the shape
that they would in the body.
Although we're currently
still using silicon,
we're also moving into
polymers and other material
to build our scaffold.
Everything is put
together in a bioreactor
and so we flow fluid
through the tissue,
just like blood would
flow through in the body.
And then we can look at it via
microscopy and measure things
and understand what's
happening in the tissue.
There are an enormous
number of applications.
In a way, almost
everything you would
like to do to human
tissue you could
think of doing in this system.
Cell cultures only goes so far.
We're trying to
capture the complexity
of the cell-cell
interactions in human tissues
and study a variety of diseases,
a variety of drug therapies,
and so forth.
It's really, I
think, a new frontier
for how we study human disease.
I can't imagine doing
this kind of research
at any other place than MIT.
MIT has really been
at the forefront of,
how do you connect
modern biology,
forefront-leading biology, with
forefront-leading engineering?
And MIT did this by
creating a special structure
in the School of Engineering
called the Division
of Biological Engineering.
So some of the faculty in
the School of Engineering
have 50/50 appointments
in this division
so we can all come together
around an interest in biology.
Some of the biology faculty are
also appointed in the division,
and we have a core
group of biologists
who are 100% in the division.
So we have a continuum
from those engineers who
don't know anything
about biology
but are inventing really
cool technologies all the way
to the biologists who
know really all the things
about stem cells but who
don't necessarily get involved
in technology development.
And the Division is a
way to do this and train
a whole new breed of students
who will go out and push
the frontier even further
by creating a new discipline
of biological engineering.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEYSER: We're going to go back
over to the Howard Johnson
Athletic Center and visit
briefly with the students who
will soon be graduating.
And they'll be making their
way over here in a procession.
If you'll take a look at the
gigantic-tron over my shoulder,
you'll see them.
Can you see them?
Blackout.
It looks like a blackout.
Oh, there they are.
So that's what the scene
looks like over there.
And you can imagine,
we've got all kinds
of people whose function it
is to line them up, get them
in the right order, because--
I don't know, how many
are graduating this year,
a couple of thousand?
2,500?
Yeah, 2,500 degrees.
And they've all got to be
lined up in alphabetical order
by schools.
So this is not an
easy thing to do.
And that's what all of
the tumult is over there.
You may have noticed while
you've been around here
that those of you who have
been to more than one MIT
commencement, you may have
noticed that the face of MIT
is changing.
We've added $1 billion
worth of new facilities,
more than 1 million square feet
of state of state-of-the-art
residential, academic,
and recreational buildings
by world-class architects,
several of them MIT associates.
This building project
is focused on improving
the quality of student life at
MIT, and boy, has it done that.
This past October, the Zesinger
Sports and Fitness Center
was opened, providing students
with a world-class recreational
complex.
MIT students work hard,
and they play hard.
And this next clip will show
you this impressive new facility
and offer a glimpse of how
MIT students like to unwind.
So take a look over my shoulder
at the humongous-otron.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEYSER: Hello, everybody.
I'm over here at the head of the
procession, where you're going
to see the students coming in.
And to my left and
right, they'll split up.
And this next tape,
the last one we're
going to show you before the
students actually come over
here, is one very
close to my heart.
I'm a musician myself.
I'm a jazz trombonist, and I'll
be playing over in the tent
by the Howard Johnson
Athletic Center later,
if you want to come
and listen to the band.
And this next one shows--
the next tape shows you that
MIT has an incredible music
program with student musicians
of amazing talent and ability.
You're going to see the
MIT Symphony Orchestra.
You'll see Marcus Thompson,
a world-class violist,
playing with a
group of students.
And you'll also see, under
the tutelage of Fred Harris,
you'll see the MIT Concert
Festival Jazz Band.
So take a look at
the gigantic-tron
over on your right.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Ellen Harris.
And as head of Music and
Theater Arts section,
it is my pleasure and
privilege to welcome you
to our gala concert, in
honor of the 50th anniversary
of the School of Humanities,
Arts, and Social Sciences.
[JAZZ MUSIC]
[CHAMBER MUSIC]
[SYMPHONIC MUSIC]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEYSER: Well, I hope
you've all gotten the idea
that MIT is a remarkable place.
We've tried to give you
a little bit of that.
As a longtime faculty member
at MIT, I am of course biased.
I love this place.
I've been here for
something like 35 years,
and I'm actually one of the
youngsters in that regard.
But this opinion of MIT
being such a great place
is not just my own.
We're going to
offer you a sampling
of thoughts and insights
about MIT from the outside.
It's been great
meeting with you.
Warren and I wish you all well.
We wish your family
and your children well.
And thank you very much.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[NO AUDIO]
- --to see MIT helping us
to train these high-level
managerial persons.
- I promise I will pay
what you are paid here.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
- I personally,
and Microsoft, have
been an incredible beneficiary
of the kind of work
that goes on here and
other places like this.
Here at MIT, over
50 years ago, there
was a vision laid
down by Vannevar Bush
that we're probably about
20% of the way to achieving.
- I can't tell you how much
I have personally benefited
from this institution.
As part of this
wonderful campaign,
I would like to put $100
million on the table.
[APPLAUSE]
- If one is unfortunate
enough to be disabled,
this is the age
in which to be so.
The disabled have a lot
to thank technology for.
I probably wouldn't
have survived,
and I certainly
wouldn't have been
able to write a
best-selling book
if I had been born any earlier.
- Managing innovation
and figuring out
how to actually turn
good ideas into products
is a really interesting
thing that you probably don't
learn about in universities.
It's not about just technology.
It's about the way
people are treated.
It's about how you
motivate people.
- What was that inspiration
which led suddenly to the world
wide web?
For me, I wanted the thing
to be a project management
tool that allowed us
all to work together.
Not management from the
top down, but management
in the working together way.
So I then said, it
should be intercreative--
a universal space for
people to communicate
through sharing knowledge.
- We are at the dawn of
a true innovation age.
It's estimated that the entire
store of human knowledge
now doubles every five years.
- I would like to thank MIT for
this incredible honor, which
is, I have to say, the first
academic honor I've ever
received.
So it's nice to
start at the top.
This is such a
great institution,
dedicated to the
search for the new
and to the openness of thought
that that search requires.
- This case is is the
great test of where
we stand on the issue of
freedom and solidarity
and the future of
our own culture.
- For in the end I believe
the real challenge of history
is to resist the tendencies
so prevalent today to label,
to stereotype, to expose,
to denigrate, and instead
to bring common sense and
empathy to our subjects
so that the past can
truly come alive if only
for a few moments in all of
its beauty, glory, sadness,
and complexity.
- Young people
like you are always
the vanguard of any
social movement,
setting an energetic tone
of courage and commitment.
And now we need you
to once again lead us
to a higher and
more noble destiny.
- 21st century America
belongs to you.
Take good care of it.
Thank you, and god bless you.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEYSER: Hello, everybody.
I keep popping up
like a bad penny.
I'm over here under the tent.
Can you see me?
I'm talking to
Larry Isaacson, who
is Assistant Director of
the Music Division at Boston
Conservatory.
Larry has been affiliated
with MIT in the past.
He was director of
the brass ensemble.
And now Larry is conducting the
music for the procession today.
I mean, no commencement would
be anywhere without music,
and we've got a terrific
conductor and ensemble here.
mass Brass it is.
Let me introduce Larry Issacson.
ISAACSON: Hello.
How are you?
KEYSER: Larry, who
do we have here?
Do we have any musicians who
actually are also at MIT here?
ISAACSON: We have several
musicians, actually,
who work here at MIT--
Bob Marlatt, who's
in our horn section,
Wes Hopper is in the
trombone section,
and Mike Epstein used
to work here at MIT.
KEYSER: And let's see, you
also have a group playing
on the front steps?
ISAACSON: Yes, we do.
And actually an MIT grad is
on the steps of 77 Mass Ave.
KEYSER: Now, Larry, I know
this is your fourth time here.
And I know that
each time you like
to do something a
little different.
What have you done different for
us for the 2003 commencement?
ISAACSON: There's two
things that we've done.
We've added some Boston
Pops-style music,
believe it or not, some
Leroy Anderson, some Strauss,
"Tritsch-Trasch Polka," and the
professionals and recessionals,
as well as a new
arrangement for Hartman--
by Hartman, called
"Festival Sounds."
And it's a wonderful
new processional
that we're going to
be using this year,
in addition to the
ceremonial march
we had commissioned three
years ago by Kevin [INAUDIBLE]..
KEYSER: That's terrific.
Thank you very much, Larry.
So I think, without
further ado, we're
going to turn to the music and
wish you all a wonderful day.
Thank you, Larry.
ISAACSON: You're welcome.
[PROCESSIONAL MUSIC]
KEYSER: [NO AUDIO] --15 minutes.
You'll be able to
tell the graduates.
They'll be the people.
Well, I've got some
good news, everyone.
The procession is underway.
We are on time and under budget.
The procession will be
here in about 15 minutes,
and it will come up
the center aisle.
And you'll recognize
the graduates.
They'll be the ones in
the long black gowns
and the funny little hats.
Now, for those of
you who are smoking,
I wonder if I could ask you
to stop smoking at this point,
both for your own safety
and for their safety
and comfort of those
around you, for the rest
of the commencement.
Thank you very much, and
have a wonderful time.
Bye-bye.
[PROCESSIONAL MUSIC]
KEYSER: [INAUDIBLE].
And we are sitting in a vantage
point beneath the stage.
But through the wonders
of modern technology,
we've got a bird's eye view
of the entire processional.
SEAMANS: Everything is
happening right in front of us.
From our vantage point,
we see the three flags
coming in under the guard
of the state police.
This will soon drive across, up
to the podium where the flags
will be planted in place.
The view here, of course,
is the main dome of MIT,
dedicated exactly 87
years ago on June 13.
You will find, as
we go through this,
we'll be talking a
lot about tradition.
MIT is an institution that is
exceedingly rich in tradition.
And we will try and pinpoint
a lot of those things
as we go through.
KEYSER: The facade
that you see up
there is, of course,
the same facade that
is burnished onto the
MIT Brass Rat, which
is the name that the students
give to the ring that they get,
their MIT class ring.
And typically
every year there is
some secret message
that is encoded
in the sides of those columns.
For the people who are
graduating, if their parents
and friends will ask
them, they can tell them
what the message is this year.
SEAMANS: Okay, directly across
from MIT is Boston's Back Bay.
You see the tallest
building is the Prudential
Center, the Sheraton
Hotel to its right,
from our vantage point, and
this is MIT's traditional view.
As we mentioned earlier,
that view across the river
is where MIT was
from 1864 until 1916.
KEYSER: The sign
on the Sheraton--
of course, if you
spell Sheraton,
it's spelled S-H-E-R-A-T-O-N.
And every year during rush,
it used to be that the students
would go up onto the roof
of the Sheraton, the students
from ATO, an MIT fraternity,
and they would block
out S-H-E-R and the N,
so that the sign would
read A-T-O. Well,
after years of futilely trying
to prevent the students from
finding their way
up to the roof,
the management of the Sheraton
agreed for safety's sake that
it would be best to
block it out themselves.
So during rush week, in
many years in the past,
you would see just A-T-O on
the roof of the Sheraton Hotel.
SEAMANS: Brightly
lit, of course,
because it was the time of year
that the lights would be on.
The other new building,
which changes this landscape
to the left of the Prudential
as we're looking at it
is one of the more phenomenal
buildings ever built in Boston.
It houses primarily law firms.
A lot of them moved from
the downtown section
to the Back Bay to be in that
particularly new building.
KEYSER: I really like
that building, Warren.
I think it really does a
lot for the Boston skyline.
Do you?
SEAMANS: No, it's growing on me.
I must admit that when
it was first going up,
it wasn't that attractive.
But now it's really
quite spectacular.
KEYSER: Yeah, it has a kind
of an art deco feel about it.
And I thought it really
was a nice punctuation.
The Boston skyline, by the
way, is, in my opinion,
one of the most
beautiful I've ever seen.
And that includes, for example,
the spectacular skyline
in Sydney, Australia.
And especially at
night on a clear night,
when you go across Mass Avenue
and you look to your left
and you see all of
the buildings lit
from the golden dome
of the City Hall
all the way up past
the Prudential Center,
it's just gorgeous.
Now, that's a marvelous
contrast, isn't it?
You see that art deco of
that new building, that dome,
and here is this solid
MIT stanchion that
has been here since when?
1916?
SEAMANS: Yes.
It was dedicated in 1916,
the work of William Welles
Bosworth, Class of
1889, who also was
known for his work in Paris.
The stage immediately
below it is
where all of the dignitaries,
faculty, and deans
will sit, as well as the
speakers and so forth.
The kite-like thing
over the top is really
a sail that was actually
designed and constructed
by MIT's own Ocean
Engineering department.
It has served to protect
the people sitting under it
from all sorts of things--
from broiling sun to rain such
as we had last year.
The flowers are done by MIT's
own grounds crew each year.
And they are sold
following the event
to raise funds for, I believe,
MIT's community service fund.
KEYSER: If you take a look
in the upper right hand
corner of the screen now, you
can see the piles of diplomas.
Those are the actual diplomas.
SEAMANS: Yes, those red stacks
of things are MIT's diplomas.
The MIT diploma has been
exactly the same since 1936.
KEYSER: That is the
State Police Honor Guard
that precedes every procession.
It is the signal that
the academic procession
is about to begin.
And you can see the state police
moving forward with the colors.
And they'll take a position
right in front of the stage
very shortly.
SEAMANS: The three flags
are, of course, the US flag,
Massachusetts, and MIT's flag.
KEYSER: And the MIT flag is the
one on the-- which one is it?
SEAMANS: It says-- it
has Massachusetts on it.
And it has also a
variation of the seal.
The seal-- which we'll
see as we turn around,
facing the stand where the
speaker will be speaking from--
is the official version of
the official MIT seal, which
was designed by MIT's founder,
William Barton Rogers in 1863,
prior to the
beginning of classes.
There's the view of the seal.
The chairs you see
in the center there
will designed by
Eduardo Catalano
to be part of the
new student center,
and that was the Julius
Stratton Student Center in 1966.
These are the few
remaining examples
of those original
chairs, by the way.
KEYSER: You know,
Bosworth-- you mentioned
that Bosworth had designed the
hall and the dome, of course.
These policemen that you see
coming down off the stage
are, in fact, not
the state police.
These are actually
MIT campus policemen.
That was my error.
And these men work during the
day keeping the campus safe
and also interacting with
the student body in as
helpful a way as possible.
There's a nice shot
of the diplomas now.
ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
the academic procession,
led by the Chief Marshal,
will now enter Killian Court.
[PROCESSIONAL MUSIC]
SEAMANS: The procession
into the Great Court
is being led by by Jim Lash, who
is President of the MIT Alumni
Association.
He is carrying the mace,
which is the official symbol
of graduation.
And we'll say a bit
more about it later.
You'll notice that the--
later came soon-- that
the very top of it
is the beaver, which, of
course, is the mascot of MIT.
And at the very bottom,
which you'll see in a minute,
is an acorn.
KEYSER: What you see
behind the President
of the Alumni Association are
the faculty in their regalia.
The regalia
represents, of course,
the universities from which
they received their own degrees.
And there is President Vest
is coming up the walk on the--
SEAMANS: On the left hand side.
KEYSER: And the gown
that he's wearing
is the newly designed MIT gown,
with the crimson and gray.
President Vest is
going to take his seat.
And there's the
members of the faculty.
That's Alec Marantz, head
of Linguistics, David Vogan,
Mathematics.
SEAMANS: Yeah, here we're
getting a close-up of the mace,
with the mascot, the
beaver, on top of it.
This was designed
by an MIT alumnus
and has been the official
symbol of graduation
for approximately 30 years.
The faculty are represented by--
50 or so of the faculty
out of a faculty of 1,000
that actually sit on
the stage representing
the rest of their colleagues.
KEYSER: Right.
I think there's actually some--
the faculty is--
yeah, that's right,
about a little bit under 1,000.
And they're up there to
represent the entire community
and to also honor
their graduates.
That's Paul Lagase, the
man in the gray suit,
that you're looking at now.
And Paul is the Chief
Marshal of the ceremonies.
And the faculty now streams
up, takes their seat.
SEAMANS: Paul is also head
of the faculty committee
that organizes the
commencement services.
Here we see two Chairmen of
the Corporation Paul Gray
is right in the center,
former president of MIT,
and former chairman
of the Corporation.
And to his right--
KEYSER: Alex d'Arbeloff,
who is the current Chair
of the Corporation.
SEAMANS: Stepping
down right now--
KEYSER: That's right.
SEAMANS: --to turn over the
reins to another chairman.
The City of Cambridge has always
represented these services.
That's Mayor Sullivan from
the good city of Cambridge.
KEYSER: That's Michael Sullivan.
And I believe his father
was Walter J. Sullivan, who
lives in Cambridge now.
He lives on Prospect Street.
SEAMANS: Each year the 50
year class, the class that
graduated 50 years ago, is
represented in the commencement
parade by all the members
attending their 50th reunion.
You will also notice they're
carrying the '53 flag.
And to the right of the stage
when you're looking at it,
there is the class
of '03's flag.
Each class has at least
two different flags.
You saw a short one being
carried by this group coming
in, and the one on
the left of the stage
is the traditional one that
joins all the other class
flags.
The red coat that
you see is the honor
that is bestowed upon
members of the 50-year class.
It is cardinal red.
And some of the ties you
see are the old freshmen tie
which represents the colors of
cardinal red and silver gray.
KEYSER: Although you
can't see them now,
but you may have caught
a glimpse of him earlier,
Warren is wearing exactly
that outfit right now.
He has a red jacket and also
a striped red and gray tie.
SEAMANS: I should explain
that I am an honorary member
of the class of
1935, which is why I
am allowed to wear a red coat.
KEYSER: My god, Warren.
I was born in 1935.
So were you?
SEAMANS: Me too.
KEYSER: Oh, I'll be darned.
What's your birthday?
SEAMANS: August 8.
KEYSER: August 8?
I'm July 7.
Now, there's a guy
wearing glasses 2003.
I wish I could identify him,
but I don't recognize him.
But those are
really cool glasses.
SEAMANS: Those certainly are.
There's a record turnout
for the 50-year class.
Starting in this period,
this is the period
immediately following
most of the returning
veterans from World
War II had graduated.
So these now tend to be
younger than the classes--
the average age of
these 50-year classes
is younger than it has been
for the last several years.
KEYSER: We should probably
mention that this telecast is
going out not only to
the 30 monitors located
all around the MIT campus
for those people who are not
sitting in the Court
itself, but it's actually
going all around the world,
from Kyoto to Carlsbad.
Warren and I probably have
an audience of hundreds--
SEAMANS: At least.
KEYSER: --out there listening
to us comment on this.
But to all of you out
there, wherever you are,
we say hello to you.
And welcome to the
MIT world webcast.
ANNOUNCER: Ladies and
gentlemen, the guests of honor,
the Class of 2003.
[APPLAUSE]
KEYSER: There's a lovely
shot over the shoulders
of the faculty.
And the students will be
coming up the center aisle.
SEAMANS: The 50-year class
have an honored place this year
to the left of the stage,
looking away from the stage.
KEYSER: There is the
procession beginning.
And the two men at the
head of the procession
are the deans of Student
Affairs on the right-- that's
Larry Benedict.
And on the left is
Bob Redwine, who's
Dean of Undergraduate Education.
This is the second or
third year now, I think,
that MIT has held these
two dual functions,
taking the undergraduate office
and dividing it up in this way.
And it's been a
remarkable success.
Both Dean Redwine
and Dean Benedict
have just done a superb job in
meeting the needs of the MIT
undergraduate student body.
We're really very lucky
to have them here.
And as you can see behind
them are the graduates
of the Class of 2003.
SEAMANS: And this year,
nearly 2,500 diplomas
will be given to both the grads
and undergraduate students.
And that is-- it's
very important
that all of these people
come in and sit exactly
in the right chair, because they
file up to get their diploma,
they have to be in the right
position to get their diploma.
It's another tradition
that every student who
graduates from MIT, who
attends a graduation ceremony,
is handed his
diploma personally.
The president
literally shakes hands
with every person
who gets a degree
from an undergraduate course.
And the provost, who is
the chief academic officer,
hands the diploma handshakes
to the person graduating
with a graduate degree.
KEYSER: Over the
years, there's been
a longstanding concern about the
size of the graduating class.
And do we really want
everyone to come up and get
their degree?
In many schools, they
actually divide the class up
into schools and have a
vulcanized graduation.
But MIT thinks that it's
important for everyone
to be recognized.
And we've done--
about 10 years ago,
we introduced this dual system,
where the students will be
coming up-- two, perhaps, one
on the left and one on the right
side of the stage--
and they'll be interweaved.
And it actually is
extremely efficient.
And everybody gets their day
in the sun-- or at least today,
their day in the shade.
SEAMANS: And every
person, in addition
to getting their diploma,
has their picture
taken receiving a diploma.
So it's all very much
part of the system.
It works very well for MIT.
There's Larry Benedict on the
right, Bob Redwine on the left
now, approaching the ramps.
They'll probably split
off, left and right.
MIT is very proud of the
fact that approximately 40%
of the graduating
class is women.
And this has crept
up over the years
to where it is something
that MIT is not only
very happy about, but it is a
wonderful sign of the times.
KEYSER: Yes, that's
absolutely right.
And the percentage
of women this year
has gone up incredibly
during my years at MIT.
And it's been a wonderful move,
not only because of the justice
of it, but it turns out that the
cost of vandalism in the dorms
went down.
Women tend to [INAUDIBLE].
SEAMANS: Very much of a
civilizing and healthy effect.
I think it's also
important to recognize
that students from
nearly 100 countries
are represented in
the student body.
And, of course, those
will be represented
here today, those same country.
KEYSER: I know everybody
likes a sunny day
because it is so pretty.
But I must say that
having sat through-- oh,
maybe 20 commencements myself--
when there are sunny days,
they can be really brutal
on the students, because
the sun is merciless.
And a day like today,
it seems to me,
is really very, very
desirable because it's dry,
but it's pleasant.
SEAMANS: For those of you who
are not in the Cambridge area,
it has been on the verge of
seeming to rain almost all day.
And we've had a very
miserable spring here.
But yesterday it
was sort of nice.
Today is sort of nice.
Saturday was a disaster.
Had this been on
Saturday, we would have
been underwater the entire day.
KEYSER: The people that you see
now, the ones with the hoods,
are people who have
received their hoods
at a special hooding ceremony
that MIT does for all
of its doctoral students.
That actually occurred yesterday
in the Howard Johnson Athletic
Center.
And it's really a
very nice ceremony.
It's an informal ceremony.
The families of all of
the doctoral students
come to watch their offspring
receive their PhD hoods.
But it also is, once
again, a time-saving thing.
Because we no
longer need to worry
about having to hood
them on the stage itself.
So this is a
typical way in which
MIT turns lemons into lemonade.
It's really a
wonderful occasion.
SEAMANS: Okay, here we have
some shots of the faculty.
KEYSER: That's
Stanford Anderson.
And the man you see
now with the black hat
with the mustache,
that's Rafael Bras.
And he is going to be the
new Chair of the Faculty,
replacing Steve Graves
who just stepped down.
There's Jay Fay in
Engineering next to him.
And let's see.
Who else do I recognize?
As I get older and they get--
there's John de Monchaux.
SEAMANS: Former Dean of
the School of Architecture.
KEYSER: Right.
And who's that?
Who else do I know?
Oh, there's Gabriel
Bitran, that's right.
Right, Subra Suresh.
Gabriel Bitran is Sloan school.
Subra Suresh is-- there's
Dan Hastings in the middle
there, with the glasses.
And he is also Engineering.
There's Eleanor Westney.
She is a marshal, and
she's looking so proud
and chipper there.
Eleanor is an expert
on Japanese industry.
She's in the Sloan school.
SEAMANS: Okay, we're
back at the mace,
with this view representing
the tradition of commencement,
which they signify
[INAUDIBLE] in all its glory.
The Corporation is the
governing body of MIT
of approximately 100 people
from all walks of life.
Only some of them are alumni.
And these are-- we're now
getting a view of some
of the Corporation.
[PROCESSIONAL MUSIC]
KEYSER: Well, our
speaker this morning--
it's always a question
of great suspense at MIT,
who the speaker is going to be.
And the president,
there's a shot
of Chuck Vest now on the
left, looking at the program.
Chuck gets input from all
kinds of sources at MIT.
And it's always a surprise and
often an occasion of delight
to see who got it right.
And our speaker
this time is someone
who needs no introduction.
Everybody knows George Mitchell.
SEAMANS: Former
Senator from Maine,
who also is the peace leader
for the North Ireland settlement
that is still sort of in effect.
He was a longtime
Senator from Maine,
and one of the greats of the--
I wish we had more like
him in the Senate today.
KEYSER: Yes, absolutely.
Two years ago, our speakers were
Click and Clack, the Car Guys.
So this is from the
sublime to the ridiculous.
SEAMANS: Well,
[INAUDIBLE] ridiculous.
KEYSER: From the
ridiculous to the sublime.
SEAMANS: I think we've had
a couple nice shots of Chuck
Vest.
Chuck has been
president now for--
I think this is his 11th year.
The Institute has gone
through phenomenal change
during that period of time.
We announced earlier that
there is more than $1 million
worth of construction taking
place, or nearing completion
on the MIT campus.
Nearly 1 million square
feet have been added,
primarily to make living easier
for the community, particularly
student housing and
student facility.
There's a brand-new
fitness center,
which is a tremendous
addition to the campus.
KEYSER: As I see the
students walking by,
you'll notice how conservative
the student body is dressed.
Every so often, you'll
see a piece of color.
There's a young man, the
Class of 2003, with a scarf.
But decorating their costume,
the academic costume,
is not so much in fashion.
SEAMANS: But also the
haircuts and so forth are
far more conservative
than they were
three years ago or 10 years
ago or certainly 20 years ago.
KEYSER: Absolutely.
Now, let's see--
SEAMANS: That my be a
sign of the economic times
as well, because
who knows what--
I'm sure everybody
of this group who
wants a job in the
outside world will
have gotten one by this
time, or be admitted
to their additional schools.
KEYSER: You wonder
what's in their hearts
as they walk up
here, because they're
leaving four years
of a university which
has, of course, got to
be one of the hardest
academic grinds in the world.
And yet it's what they do,
and what they do very well.
SEAMANS: Our treasurer.
KEYSER: There's our
treasurer, Allan Bufferd,
disappearing out of the right.
So the students, it's got to be
a bittersweet moment for them,
because they're
leaving a marvelous
environment, some place
where they can [INAUDIBLE]..
SEAMANS: There's a Corporation
member, [INAUDIBLE]..
KEYSER: Oh, yes.
Those are three members.
SEAMANS: Class of '45.
KEYSER: And it's a bittersweet
moment for the student.
SEAMANS: [INAUDIBLE].
KEYSER: Oh, there's in the
back, putting his hat on,
that's Steve Lerman.
SEAMANS: Oh, yes.
KEYSER: He's a house master
at the new graduate dorm
on, I think, Albany Street.
I think they call
it the warehouse.
That's Ros Williams,
her hand to her chin.
She used to be Dean of
Undergraduate Education.
She's Science
Technology Society.
That's Wesley Harris
behind with the orange--
SEAMANS: Vest
KEYSER: --hood.
And he's talking
to Steve Lippard,
who is the head of the
Department of Chemistry.
I was talking to
Steve the other day.
I mean, he's one of the
country's great chemists.
And he told me that he had
majored in English literature
in undergraduate,
as an undergraduate.
He always wondered--
there's somebody with a--
there, he's got a little
teddy bear on his [INAUDIBLE]..
Good for you.
There's somebody holding a--
no, just a tassel.
SEAMANS: Okay, the
stage mysteriously
appears here in Killian Court
every year, about 10 days ahead
of the commencement services.
And then a day later,
it totally disappears.
It is a phenomenal
piece of a jigsaw puzzle
that goes together so
readily and so easily
that it seems almost like
a miracle that appears,
and then suddenly it's gone.
KEYSER: Warren
and I are actually
sitting underneath
that stage right now.
The faculty is
right on top of us.
And sitting here, we
have a beautiful view
of the joists that
hold up the stage.
And I can't help but wishing
that my house were as well
built as this stage.
SEAMANS: You see the Class of
2003's flag just to the right,
as it's moving off screen.
KEYSER: There's one of MIT's
favorite venues for hacks.
Of course, the great
hack was the police car
on the dome about
five or six years ago,
when the MIT community--
SEAMANS: I hate to tell
you, Jay, it's 11 years ago.
KEYSER: Oh, no.
Was it 11 years?
SEAMANS: 11 years.
KEYSER: Oh, god.
SEAMANS: But one thing we
need to comment perhaps on
is, those who are
graduating with a degree
from a commissioning from one
of the US military services
wear those uniforms.
You see the Navy in white.
You saw somebody with
an Air Force cap before.
So that is part of the tradition
as well, not only here,
but in every school.
KEYSER: I think we have
all three services.
SEAMANS: Yes, we do.
KEYSER: Army,
Navy, and Air Force
ROTC, and they're graduating.
There's Michael Sullivan
next to Paul Gray.
And in the lower
left hand corner,
you can see the shot there of
Allan Bufferd, the Institute
treasurer.
And Michael Sullivan
is, of course,
the one without the hat.
You could see Paul Gray
leaning over talking to him.
He was probably trying to
get a parking ticket fixed.
And here's a nice shot
over the shoulders.
There's Tom Magnanti
on the left there.
He's the Dean of the
School of Engineering.
Warren, I'm surprised
that the MIT
flag doesn't have gray in it.
SEAMANS: I am surprised as well.
KEYSER: In fact, it's
neither crimson nor gray.
No, I agree.
SEAMANS: It looks sort
of like a salmon color.
KEYSER: There's Brit d'Arbeloff,
Alex d'Arbeloff's spouse.
He's the Chairman of the
Corporation now stepping down.
SEAMANS: And also an alumna.
KEYSER: She's an
engineer, I think.
SEAMANS: Yes.
KEYSER: From the
School of Engineering.
SEAMANS: Coming to Becky Vest,
current First Lady of MIT.
This is Priscilla
Gray, who has--
obviously Paul Gray's wife.
And so she has been both First
Lady and First Corporation
woman.
KEYSER: Laura Mersky is
sitting next to Priscilla.
And Laura is President
Vest's special assistant.
And next to Laura
is Paul Parravano,
who is MIT Liaison with
the town of Cambridge.
And next to Paul is [INAUDIBLE].
He works for Gail Gallagher,
who is the éminence grise
of the commencement.
She is the--
SEAMANS: The major-domo.
She tells us all what to do.
KEYSER: She's the one
who makes it all happen.
There's a lei.
SEAMANS: Obviously we
know where she's from.
There's somebody
with a cell phone.
KEYSER: There's somebody with
a decorated tab, but we can't--
there's another lei.
SEAMANS: We do have a large
number of students from Hawaii.
Hawaii has some absolutely
superb school systems,
and they send a
disproportionately high number
of students to MIT.
KEYSER: From Hawaii?
SEAMANS: Yes.
KEYSER: Have you
ever visited Hawaii?
SEAMANS: No, I haven't.
KEYSER: Neither have I.
SEAMANS: But over the
years, as freshman advisees,
it seems like every
other year, I always
have somebody from Hawaii.
KEYSER: Some more PhDs.
[INAUDIBLE] gold hood.
It's Doctor of Science, I think.
SEAMANS: Just again,
briefly, those
who are watching
as we get through--
we will be leaving you as soon
as the commencement services
start.
Then there will be
the introductions
of various of the senior
class, of the 50-year class.
There will be Chuck Vest's
charge to the students,
plus the keynote speech
by George Mitchell,
not necessarily in that order.
Then they will start
distributing the diplomas,
and they will be
done simultaneously.
The Grad School and the
Undergraduate School
are going up individually to
receive their diplomas directly
from either their
president or the provost.
It is also one more
tradition, it's
interesting to
note, we've talked
about the ring, the brass
rat, that a good number
of the students wear.
It's a tradition that
immediately following
the receipt of the
diploma, the ring
is turned around so that
the beaver faces the world.
As an undergraduate, the beaver
faces the bearer of the ring.
This is a longstanding
tradition,
and it has something
to do with--
KEYSER: Look at that--
four cell phones.
Right there, four cell phones.
They're all talking
on cell phones.
Now there's a change.
Look, five-- one, two,
three, four, five.
Who in the world
are they talking to?
I mean, look, six cell phones!
My god.
Look, there'll be even
seven cell phones.
They'll even be
talking cell phones
as they walk up on the stage.
SEAMANS: Can't miss-- look how--
KEYSER: Amazing.
SEAMANS: I assume they're
talking to their parents
in the back rows and so forth.
KEYSER: Amazing shot.
SEAMANS: Who knows?
That is a change that has--
KEYSER: That's a real change.
SEAMANS: --you didn't notice
last year or previous years.
KEYSER: Right.
Those are the Navy
graduates, Navy ROTC.
SEAMANS: Another phone.
KEYSER: Another cell phone.
SEAMANS: I wonder if we'll
have to make an announcement
to have everybody turn
their cell phone--
KEYSER: I'll be
you they're going
to have to because
it might interfere
with the sound system.
So what do we have?
We have 2,500 graduating today?
SEAMANS: 2,500
diplomas given out.
There's actually-- a lot
of those are duplicate.
By that, a person gets
two degrees at once.
KEYSER: Because
there's a lot of--
right, dual majors.
SEAMANS: And there's about 1,000
from the undergraduate school.
And probably about 1,200
from the graduate school,
individuals that receive them.
KEYSER: Right.
And then there's
2,200, 2,500 degrees.
SEAMANS: And some of
the undergraduates
will receive a master's
degree as well as
an undergraduate degree.
But it totals up to
about that amount.
And that has remained con--
Yeah, here they are.
They're all keeping in touch
with one another, just in case.
KEYSER: Yeah.
You see those two guys with
their backs to one another.
They're actually
talking to one another.
You see, they--
SEAMANS: Uh-oh.
KEYSER: Uh-oh.
Yeah, they've--
now they're waving.
Yeah, look.
He's telling the guy
next to him, look.
Look at the camera.
That's the new generation.
Yes, that's right.
You're either talking to
the world over a cell phone
or looking at it through
the lens of a camera.
SEAMANS: Yes.
KEYSER: I mean, I
suppose I can't really
take a superior position,
since I wear glasses.
She's tired, and we
haven't even started yet.
There's a female
graduate of the--
SEAMANS: Navy ROTC.
KEYSER: I do wish they'd
be a little more inventive
with their mortarboards.
SEAMANS: Yeah, that phase
seems to have passed.
KEYSER: The color of the--
you've probably
noticed-- there is
Rafael Bras on the right, the
incoming Chair of the Faculty.
And you can see he has a
rather unusual and ornate
academic costume.
I believe that's from
the University of Toledo,
is that right, in Spain.
SEAMANS: Yes.
KEYSER: And you can see it
has a bib and gold embroidery.
You'll notice that the
way it works in academia
is the higher up you get, the
more ridiculous the costume.
SEAMANS: Well, I
guess you have to have
something that embarrasses you,
reaching such a high level.
KEYSER: But you know
what was really good?
Yesterday, after the
hooding ceremony,
I walked into the
coffee shop in Lobby 7.
And the woman who was serving
me, her name was Carrie,
she had a hat on which looked
exactly like the hat I had on.
So I asked her if I could
come behind the counter
and help her--
SEAMANS: Get a good paying job?
KEYSER: She welcomed
me behind there.
I went behind the counter and
served a couple of customers.
Well, I always
kept my mortarboard
on throughout these ceremonies
because I knew that there'd
be camera shots like this.
And I'm losing a lot of my hair.
SEAMANS: Well, you don't have
to worry about that under here,
because nobody can really see--
KEYSER: Nobody's looking, right.
That's the great
thing about this job.
Nobody can see us.
Now, there's Suzanne
Flynn, the Department
of Linguistics and Philosophy,
who's straightening her hair.
SEAMANS: Without
her mortarboard.
KEYSER: In between those two
august-looking gentlemen.
And next to her on the
left is Pete Donaldson,
who has done some wonderful work
in putting Shakespeare onto--
SEAMANS: DVD and other--
KEYSER: --DVDs.
And there's Phil
Clay, the upper right,
with his hand on his chin.
And he's the Chancellor.
And talking to him is Bob
Brown, who's the MIT Provost.
SEAMANS: The chief
academic officer.
KEYSER: The chief
And the two of those are
really the people who
report directly to Chuck Vest.
And there, to the right, is the
outgoing Chair of the Faculty.
That's Steve Graves, I believe.
And in front is Paul Legase,
who is Chair of the Commencement
Committee, and one of the chief
organizers of this event, one
of the chief shepherds.
And next to him is
Eleanor Westney,
who is an expert on Japanese--
SEAMANS: Technology.
KEYSER: --industry.
SEAMANS: Industry.
KEYSER: And she's
in the Sloan School.
SEAMANS: Well, we don't
have that blue sky,
but at least we
don't have sheets
of rain coming down
as we did last year
at this particular juncture.
KEYSER: You really
have to have experience
of a whole host of
these under your belt
to know how nice it is a day.
I remember one time that
it was pouring rain,
and there was a
20-knot wind, and I
thought that the
sail was actually
going to take off and carry
us all up into the steps.
SEAMANS: From the
opposite extreme,
in 1930, when Carl Compton was
inaugurated in the Great Court,
as it was known at that time,
it was over 100 degrees in the--
KEYSER: Well, that's brutal.
SEAMANS: Because people just
were fainting it was so hot.
In fact, the only people who
stayed out were the faculty.
Everybody else was lined up
against the side of the--
in the shade of the
buildings and of the trees.
KEYSER: Well, there's
Larry Benedict.
SEAMANS: The mace is
being [INAUDIBLE]..
KEYSER: [INAUDIBLE] is
carrying the mace up now, yep.
SEAMANS: Again,
the symbol of MIT,
transferring its degree-giving
power to the students.
There's the seal again.
The seal, which you will
have lots of views of it
during the ceremony,
will indicate--
you have two figures on
either side of an anvil.
And these are, again,
the mind and the hand,
which are part of the--
KEYSER: We're going
to say goodbye now.
The program is about to start.
D'ARBELOFF: The Corporation
and the faculty--
So so long everyone.
D'ARBELOFF: --of the
Massachusetts Institute
of Technology--
KEYSER: This is Jay Keyser.
SEAMANS: And Warren Seamans.
D'ARBELOFF: --are now
declared convened.
Together with this
assembly on the occasion
of the commencement
exercises of this Institution
for the conferring
of its degrees.
The stage assembly
and audience will
please rise for the invocation
by Reverend Paul Reynolds,
and remain standing
to join the MIT
Chorallaries in the
singing of one verse
of "The Star-Spangled Banner."
REYNOLDS: Shalom, salaam, peace.
Creator of life, bless us as
we gather in your presence.
Your spirit of wisdom
fills the earth,
reminding us that we
are sisters and brothers
in a single human family.
Pour out your blessings
on these women and men,
graduates of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Sustain the passion
of their intelligence,
and nurture in them
a restless curiosity,
which marvels at the intricacy
of the universe and revels
in its beauty and wonder.
Sharpen the focus
of their insights
and temper the generosity
of their hearts
with deepening compassion
for themselves and others,
that they may always
carry a thirst for truth,
a longing for justice, and
an abiding sense of hope.
Enclose them in the
circle of your care,
and create in them the courage
of honest conviction, that you
may use the work of their
hands in the service
of the family of nations.
Pour out your joy on
their family and friends
during these festive
days of celebration,
and nurture always the
life of this Institute
and its community of research,
scholarship, and service.
May our graduates go forth
into the world and their future
with a passion for
knowledge and wisdom.
May they go forth into the
world and illumine the universe
with hope and light.
And with our well-wishes to
accompany them on their way,
may they set the world on
fire with love for peace
and for justice.
Shalom, salaam, peace.
Creator of life, bless us as
we gather in your presence.
Amen.
[MUSIC - "THE STAR SPANGLED
BANNER"]
CHORALLARIES: (SINGING)
O, say can you see,
by the dawn's early
light, what so proudly
we hailed at the twilight's
last gleaming, whose
broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous fight,
o'er the ramparts we watched
were so gallantly streaming?
And the rockets' red glare,
the bombs bursting in air
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there.
O, say does that star-spangled
banner yet wave o'er
the land of the free and
the home of the brave?
[APPLAUSE]
D'ARBELOFF: Be seated.
I am pleased to welcome to the
platform George J. Mitchell,
former United States
Senator from Maine,
and the honorable Michael
A. Sullivan, Mayor
of the City of Cambridge.
Senator Mitchell will
now give the address.
[APPLAUSE]
MITCHELL: To the graduates,
their families and friends,
it's an honor for me to be
part of this important day
in your lives.
I know that many of you already
are worrying about how long I'm
going to speak.
So I begin by reassuring
you that my intention is
to stop speaking before you
graduates stop listening.
I've been asked
to discuss my work
in conflict resolution in
Northern Ireland and the Middle
East.
Mindful of the commitment
I've just made,
my comments will
have to be brief.
I spent five years working
for peace in Northern Ireland.
For almost all of that
time, there was no progress.
There was political
posturing, delay, doubt,
and many people died.
After each death, I
spent a sleepless night
trying to fight off a growing
feeling of despair and failure.
But after years of
effort, a peace agreement
was finally reached.
From that experience,
I formed the conviction
that there is no such thing as
a conflict that can't be ended.
Conflicts are
created, conducted,
and sustained by human beings.
They can be ended
by human beings.
After completing my work
in Northern Ireland,
I was asked to go
to the Middle East.
There, the committee
which I chaired
made recommendations which
have been incorporated
into the roadmap,
recently advanced
by the United States, the
United Nations, the European
Union, and Russia.
As we all know, last week
it was accepted by Israel
and the Palestinian Authority.
Although only a first step,
that acceptance was significant.
And it reinforces my conviction
that like all others,
the conflict in the
Middle East can be ended.
Among the steps we
recommended and which
are included in the roadmap are
by the Palestinian Authority
the renunciation of violence,
an end to hatred and incitement,
and a 100% effort to crack down
on terrorism, an effort which
has not yet been made.
By the government of Israel,
the withdrawal of its military
forces to their
pre-intifada positions,
and the freezing of all
settlement construction
activity.
Then there must be
a prompt resumption
of negotiations to achieve
a two-state solution.
What is most important
is that both recognize
that the only way to
achieve a lasting solution
is through negotiation.
If they are to
succeed, illusions
must be abandoned on both sides.
Some Palestinians
and other Arabs
continue to believe
that they can
destroy Israel and rid the
Middle East of a Jewish state.
That cannot and will not happen.
It is a fantasy that will
only generate more misery
and suffering on both sides.
Some Israelis
believe and advocate
that all of the Palestinians--
every man, woman, and child--
can be physically uprooted
and moved to another country.
That cannot and will not happen.
It, too, is a fantasy.
Contributing to the
difficulty of finding
a peaceful resolution
is the fact
that the circumstances and
objectives of the two sides
are different.
The Israelis have a state.
What they want is security.
That is their
overriding objective.
The Palestinians don't have
a state, and they want one--
an independent, economically
viable, geographically
contiguous state.
That is their
overriding objective.
I believe that neither
can attain its objective
by denying to the other
side its objective.
Palestinians will
never achieve a state
if Israel does
not have security.
Israel will never get
sustainable security
if the Palestinians
don't have a state.
There are some in
both societies--
perhaps some here today--
who disagree with
this assertion.
But for me, it
has been validated
by the tragic events of the
past two and a half years.
Our committee's report was
very tough on terrorism.
We branded it "morally
reprehensible and
unacceptable."
It is also politically
counterproductive.
It will not achieve
its objective.
To the contrary, with
each suicide bomb attack,
the prospect of a
Palestinian state is delayed.
Such tactics also
are destructive
of Palestinian civil
society and the reputation
of the Palestinian people
throughout the world.
The roadmap offers
Palestinians the alternative
of a nonviolent path
to a Jewish state--
to a Palestinian state living in
peace alongside a Jewish state,
the two-state solution that
a majority on both sides
continue to say they support.
Palestinians, in
turn, must accept
that the Israeli
demand for security
is as real and as necessary as
is their demand for a state.
Both are more likely to occur
if reciprocal steps are taken
to create a context in which
meaningful negotiation can
be conducted.
This can't be done by
the two sides themselves.
Their mutual mistrust is total.
The culture of peace,
so carefully nurtured
over the previous decade,
has been shattered.
In its place,
there has developed
a sense of futility and
despair of the inevitability
of conflict.
And yet public opinion
polls on both sides
show consistent and
strong majorities
in support of a
two-state solution
and of the political process
needed to bring it about.
But because of the impact
of the prolonged violence
a majority of Palestinians
support suicide bombings
of Israelis, and a
majority of Israelis
support the use
of whatever force
is deemed necessary to
suppress such attacks.
In other words,
majorities on both sides
largely agree on the solution,
but they no longer trust
the other side's
intentions to reach it.
They're caught in
a zero-sum contest
in which both are suffering.
Time does not
permit me to repeat
the long list of our
committee's recommendations
or the details of the roadmap.
Most attention has been given
to the cessation of violence
and incitement by Palestinians
and a freeze on all settlement
construction
activity by Israelis.
I have already commented on and
condemned the failure of terror
to advance the
Palestinian cause.
As to settlements,
our committee adopted
what has been the policy of
every American administration
for more than a
quarter of a century.
During the more than 50
years of its existence,
Israel has had the strong
support of the United States.
In international forums,
the US has at times
cast the only vote
in Israel's behalf.
Yet even in such a
close relationship,
there are some differences.
Prominent among them is the
United States government's
long-standing opposition
to the government
of Israel's policies
and practices regarding
settlements.
That US opposition
has been consistent
through the Carter, Reagan,
Bush, Clinton, and Bush
administrations.
Just as consistent has been the
continued settlement activity
by the Israeli government.
It his major policy
speech on the Middle East
last year, President
Bush was explicit.
He said, and I quote,
"Israeli settlement activity
in the occupied territories
must stop, consistent
with the recommendations
of the Mitchell committee."
The roadmap also
refers specifically
to our recommendations
on settlements.
As we read in this
morning's newspaper,
there already are
serious problems
in implementation of the
roadmap's recommendations.
There will be more.
So I don't underestimate
the difficulties.
But I believe that an end to
this conflict is possible.
It is especially important
that we Americans not turn away
when the inevitable
setbacks occur,
that we not resign ourselves to
the inevitability of conflict.
American commitment
and determination
are essential to
the preservation
of a sovereign and secure Israel
and to the peaceful and just
resolution of the conflict
in the Middle East.
There, as elsewhere, there
is a universal human desire
to lead lives that are
full, free, and meaningful.
Because of the
wisdom and foresight
of our founding fathers,
we're fortunate to live
in a society which
despite its imperfections
is the most free, the most just,
the most open society in all
of human history.
From that society, each of
us receives many benefits.
With benefits come
responsibilities.
You've had the good fortune to
receive an advanced education,
so you have an important
role to play in preserving
and improving our way of life.
There is much for
all of us to do.
Each of you students,
graduates, undergraduates,
every person present
today, will have
your own list of our
society's domestic challenges.
I will mention just a few
that are important to me.
If you believe, as I do,
that every American child is
entitled to a good education,
regardless of background
or family wealth,
you must oppose
any actions which have
the effect of denying
them that opportunity.
If you believe, as I do,
that we have an obligation
to leave for future
generations the very basics
of healthy human life--
clean air, pure water,
unpoisoned land--
you must demand public policies
to honor that obligation.
If you believe, as I do, that
every American is entitled
to equal opportunity
and equal justice,
you must speak out against
all forms of discrimination
and injustice.
Never forget that in
the presence of evil,
silence makes you an accomplice.
The education you have received
that this great institution is
important, even
necessary, but it is not
a guarantee of self-worth.
It is not a substitute
for a life of effort.
How you do it is important--
just as important
as what you do.
If you take pride in what
you do, you will excel.
If you do not take pride in
what you do, you cannot excel.
John Gardner put it best when he
wrote, "An excellent plumber is
infinitely more admirable than
an incompetent philosopher.
The society which scorns
excellence in plumbing,
because it regards that
as a humble activity,
and tolerates shoddiness
in philosophy,
because it is an
exalted activity,
will have neither good
plumbing nor good philosophy.
Neither its pipes nor its
theories will hold water."
For those undergraduates
going on to further education,
I have some advice
on what not to do.
I serve as the
Chancellor of the Queen's
University of Northern Ireland.
Last December, our students
took a graduate school entrance
exam.
One of them, frustrated by the
difficulty of the questions,
wrote, in answer to
the last question,
"God alone knows the
answer to this question.
Merry Christmas."
Two weeks later, he got his
paper back with this note.
"God gets an A. You fail.
Happy new year."
You are part of a highly
privileged elite--
in the education you
received, in the opportunities
that will be available to you.
It is inevitable and
appropriate that you
devote much of your
life to earning
the income you need to support
yourself and your family.
Like all human beings, you
will want status and wealth,
and most of you will get them.
But the more successful
you are, the more evident
it will become to you that
there is more to life.
You will find that
fulfillment in your life
will not come from the
expensive things you
acquire, not from leisure,
not from self-indulgence.
Real fulfillment
in life will come
from striving with all of your
physical and spiritual might
for a worthwhile objective
that helps others and is larger
than your self-interest.
Most of all for you graduates,
I hope that each of you
is fortunate enough to find
such an objective in your life.
Congratulations.
Good luck.
May God bless each one of you.
[APPLAUSE]
D'ARBELOFF: Thank
you, Senator Mitchell.
These are words that give
us hope for the future.
And we all hope that the
parties in the Middle East
follow the Mitchell Report
and the resulting roadmap.
And also, you've given the
graduates a wonderful roadmap
for their future.
Thank you.
Now, Mr. Suneth Wijesinghe,
President of the Graduate
Student Council, will
give a salute to MIT
from the graduate student body.
Following this, Mr.
Sina Kevin Nazemi,
President of the Senior Class,
will present the class gift
to President Vest, after which
the President will deliver
his charge to the graduates.
WIJESINGHE: Fellow
colleagues, Sigmund Freud,
the great medical
doctor and psychologist,
is quoted as saying,
"One day, in retrospect,
the years of struggle
will strike you
as the most beautiful."
Indeed, as we gather here
today in Killian Court
to celebrate our accomplishment
on becoming MIT's newest
ambassadors to the nation
and the world at large,
it is a time to reflect on those
memories and experiences that
have shaped our
journey here at MIT.
Now, you might ask
yourself what hope there
is to find beauty in struggle.
Ultimately, this will depend
on your particular definition
of beauty.
However the writer and
educator Walter Pater
gives us some guidelines.
"Beauty, like all
other qualities
presented to human
experience, is relative.
And the definition of it
becomes unmeaning and useless
in proportion to
its abstractness.
To define beauty not
in the most abstract
but in the most concrete
terms possible, not
to find a universal
formula for it
but the formula which
expresses most adequately
this or that special
manifestation of it,
is the aim of the true
student of aesthetics."
Hence, in order to remember
those special manifestations
or expressions of beauty, I ask
that you take your mind back
to the start of your MIT journey
and remember the excitement you
felt on the day you received
the letter announcing
your admission, the first
days at orientation,
settling into a new home
and academic department,
your first class
and problems sets,
tailored to a very unique
style of MIT education,
one that teaches you how
to learn and to think,
and the challenging research
and teaching you undertook where
you were given opportunities
to make your mark on the world.
There are bound to be very
personal expressions of beauty
captured here in a landscape
of ideas, relationships,
and emotions.
While the specifics
of our experiences
may be quite varied, there
are many common threads
that do, however, bind
our collective endeavors.
On the surface, this consists
of a shared sense of place,
defined by our living
and working spaces,
a shared passage
of time, captured
by the pace and intensity
of our daily chores,
and perhaps the most profound,
a shared sense of attraction
to events with free food.
But beyond this
is a common thread
that I believe is especially
unique to graduates of MIT.
This is a quality that allows
us to seamlessly relate
to one another when we meet in
five, 10, 15, or even 50 years
from now.
This is a quality
of unbounded passion
that we bring to bear
on any activity that
captures our hearts, our
minds, and our souls.
It is this passion that
crystallizes solutions
to serve fellow
citizens, that pushes
the boundaries of research and
teaching excellence, and which
fuels scientific, technological,
and business innovation.
Passion has indeed
defined the journey
we embarked on here at MIT and
is the very source of beauty
in any endeavor of excellence.
As you take on the role of an
MIT ambassador to the world,
your demonstrated
passion for excellence
will translate to a unique style
of leadership second to none.
I charge you to motivate,
inspire, and assist
those around you to
formulate and reach
new goals through high standards
of professionalism, courtesy,
and mutual respect.
But more importantly, I charge
you to help realize solutions
for a society that is seeking
to find new meaning and new role
models.
In closing, I encourage you
to maintain relationships
with the multitude
of student groups
that you may have been
involved with and benefited
from over the years.
By and large, we
cherish most experiences
we share with our
friends and colleagues.
And student groups undoubtedly
played the greatest part
in helping to
create these bonds.
I encourage you to
serve as a mentor
to the new generation
of student leaders
who will face many of the
same challenges that you did.
With that, I'd like
to congratulate you
all once again on reaching
the conclusion of one journey
and the start of another.
Here's wishing you the very
best of good fortune in all
your future endeavors.
[APPLAUSE]
NAZEMI: My fellow graduates,
it's been quite a journey.
Four years, 72 freshmen year
problem sets, 4,394 Anne Hunter
emails, eight MIT Nobel
Prizes, 15 calls to mom and dad
asking for more money,
30,000 sequenced human genes,
45 hacks, 43 Sloan
C-Functions, one dot-com boom,
one dot-com bust, and finally
a 786 smoot procession
from Johnson Athletic
Center to Killian Court, we,
the 2,202 graduates of the
MIT class of 2003 are here.
[APPLAUSE]
Giving the parting
words is difficult.
We can leave obvious advice
for the next generation.
If your GPA is
suffering, cross-register
for classes at Harvard.
But on a more serious
note, we have all
been given the greatest gift
anyone could ever ask for--
the gift of opportunity.
We are all here because of the
sacrifices of our loved ones.
For many of us, the sacrifices
involved our loved ones
leaving their homelands
and their families
in the name of creating
opportunities for us.
While the stories of
sacrifice differ among us,
graduation for all
of us represents
not just our own work but
also that of our loved ones.
Let us clearly say to them
on this day of celebration,
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
As the old adage
goes, much is expected
from those to whom
much has been given.
We have been blessed with a lot.
It's time for us to give back.
We can leave MIT merely
being reactive to the world's
problems, considering
the world's problems
in the abstract
and at a distance.
But it is my hope that we leave
the world being active world
citizens.
The route of treating
the world's problems
in the abstract
and at a distance
will likely be comfortable, both
financially and emotionally,
and we may very well be deemed
as extremely successful people.
On the other hand, we
can leave MIT committing
to actively engaging the
world's many and growing
problems by saying
what needs to be said,
doing what needs to be done.
We can look at problems
like world poverty
not as mere statistics
but as challenges--
challenges we are
willing to face head on.
My fellow classmates, the
commitment need not be uniform.
I hope that each of us
finds it within ourselves
to take a few moments at every
stage of the very busy lives
that we are likely to lead
to reflect on where we can be
active, on where our
words and our actions
can have great impact.
While making such a
commitment may not
result in as comfortable a
life as merely being reactive,
it has the collective
potential to be revolutionary.
I'd like to end this morning
with a story once shared
with me about a boy named Jimmy.
On one of the few
days this school year
when the sun was
shining in Cambridge,
Jimmy grabbed his
baseball and glove
and approached his father, who
was sitting on the living room
couch, reading his copy of MIT's
Technology Review magazine.
Dad, let's go play
catch, Jimmy begged.
Not now, son.
I'm reading a magazine.
Well, Jimmy went away
for about two minutes.
And he came back
and he said, Dad,
can we go out and
play catch now?
You said later.
It's later.
Father, trying to occupy Jimmy's
time so he could get back
to reading his magazine,
flipped through the magazine
to a page with a picture of
the world from space on it.
And he tore the page out, and
he ripped it into small pieces.
He said, son, Jimmy, when you
put the pieces of the world
together, we will go
out and play catch.
Well, the father went back
to reading his magazine,
and to his surprise, Jimmy came
back just two minutes later
with the pieces of the
world all taped together.
The father was shocked.
He said, son, Jimmy,
how did you do that?
How did you put the world
together so quickly?
The world is so complicated.
Jimmy smiled, and
he held up the page
with the picture
of the world on it,
and he flipped it
over and showed
his father that on the other
side was a picture of a man.
He said, Dad, it was easy.
I put the man together, and the
world came together by itself.
[APPLAUSE]
My fellow classmates,
today is our day.
And shortly this
will be our world.
Let us better
ourselves and the world
we inherit by putting
ourselves together
as active world citizens.
Thank you.
I now have the
privilege of taking part
in two MIT traditions, the
first being the turning
of our MIT ring, the Brass Rat.
I now ask all graduates to
join me in taking off your ring
and turning the beaver around
to officially let the world know
that you are an MIT graduate.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
I would now like to invite
President Vest to join me
on the stage for
the presentation
of the senior gift.
Dr. Vest, I'm proud to announce
that 25% of the members
of the Class of 2003 have
contributed to our senior gift,
for a total of $28,187.
[APPLAUSE]
Part of this money
will be used to fund
a seal of the Institute,
which will be placed
in the main lobby
of MIT, Lobby 7,
as well as a scholarship
fund for future MIT students.
The amount of our gift
has been made possible
by the President of the Alumni
Association, Jim Lash, who
has progressively
matched our donations.
Mr. Lash, thank you.
Dr. Vest, on behalf of
the MIT class of 2003,
I proudly present to
you our senior gift.
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Thank you very much,
Mr. Nazemi and Mr. Wijesinghe.
I am most grateful for
your words and your gifts
but especially for all that
you and your fellow students
have meant to this
great institution.
At this time, I want
to take particular note
of a group of
remarkable individuals
here today, the members
of the Class of 1953.
You can recognize them
by their red jackets--
[APPLAUSE]
--by their red jackets
and, I suspect,
by a certain aura of experience
they carry with them.
The world has changed greatly
since their own graduation.
And with all that
they have witnessed
in the intervening years,
I am sure that they
could tell us much about what
is truly valuable in life.
And they could also
tell us about one thing
that never changes--
the pride you take
in knowing that you
have earned a degree from MIT.
To the Class of 1953, welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
So here we are, gathered
once again in Killian Court
to celebrate accomplishment,
heritage, and passage.
It may perhaps seem
odd that a community so
dedicated to the future
comes together donning
strange and colorful
medieval regalia.
But indeed, it is
fitting and seemingly
fulfilling of a deep human need
that such rituals take place.
One of our MIT poets,
Professor Stephen Tapscott
has reminded us, however,
that the solemnity
of such elegant
scenes is sometimes
broken by the faculty themselves
when, as he once wrote,
"From deep in the drooping
sleeves of their robes,
surreptitiously they bring
out peanut butter sandwiches
to sustain them during
the long ceremony."
Be that as it may, this ritual
reminds us of the continuity
through the ages of our role in
an unbroken centuries-old chain
of discovery and accomplishment.
But above all it celebrates
your accomplishments
during your student years.
This is not to say that
you have accomplished
this remarkable
feat of graduating
from MIT on your own.
We are surrounded by parents,
family, spouses, and children,
who have supported and sustained
you through these years.
You will recognize them today
by their smiles, brought
about by their great
relief, by their great pride
in your accomplishment,
and no doubt
by a sense of great relief
to their bank accounts.
We are very grateful
that they are all here.
And it is also
especially wonderful
to see the babies and
small children who
come to see their mothers and
fathers, sisters and brothers,
graduate.
They too are welcome.
And as this ceremony
stretches onward,
I give them special
presidential approval
to comment upon the proceedings
at any time and in any manner
they see fit.
And now some thoughts
for our students.
You are soon to become graduates
of one of the world's most
prestigious universities.
We celebrate your journey
to this graduation,
but more importantly,
we look forward
to the continuation
of your journey
as you dedicate your talents
and scholarship to the service
of your nations and the world.
The world we share today is
one of enormous complexity.
At the dawn of this
new century, we
have unprecedented
capabilities and opportunities
in science and engineering
to explore and improve
the human condition.
Indeed, this is the most
exciting period in science
and its applications
in all of history.
We have before us the
ability to come ever closer
to understanding the
origins of our universe
and the life within it.
We can learn the evasive
facts of dark energy
and dark matter that
may pervade our cosmos.
We are accelerating
our understanding
of the human brain and mind.
We have mapped the human
genome, and now begins
the task of relating this
knowledge to the origins
and resolution of disease.
We have the ability to
improve human learning
and communication.
We can now build materials and
devices at the molecular level
and can mimic more closely the
beautiful and efficient designs
found in nature.
We can dramatically improve
our use of energy and materials
and learn to better steward
our Earth's environment.
We can learn to feed and shelter
the peoples of our planet.
Behind the advances in each
of these areas of knowledge
and of challenge lies
some common features.
They all require work at the
highest levels of complexity.
They all cross
traditional boundaries--
boundaries between
academic disciplines,
between academia,
industry, and government,
and between nations and
peoples around the globe.
Many of these advances
originate in the ability
to think more holistically,
think more in terms of systems,
to combine and integrate
as well as to apply
reductionist concepts.
The advance of
knowledge increasingly
comes from combining and
pulling together rather than
breaking down into finer
and finer elements.
As graduates of MIT,
you of all people
stand ready to
drive these advances
and lead their
wise applications.
You can make a better future.
Gerard O'Neill once
discussed the work
of those who had
made serious attempts
at various stages of history
to predict the future.
He analyzed whether those
predictions had come true.
What he learned was
that we invariably
underestimate the rate of
scientific and technological
progress, and we invariably
and dramatically overestimate
the rate of social progress.
So you should strive to
change this situation,
to bring better harmony
to technology and society.
As you work to advance
scientific and engineering
knowledge or to apply
it, you must increasingly
understand the social,
political, economic, artistic,
and historical contexts
in which you work.
And when you do so, I
think that in these realms,
you too will find
a familiar tension.
Because our social and political
world also is subject to two
opposing forces.
One force is that
of fragmentation,
pulling us apart.
The other force is that of
integration and connection,
bringing us together.
We are increasingly fragmented
by politics, poverty, hatred,
absolutism, and fear.
Yet we are pulled together
by information technology,
by the challenges of the Earth's
environment that we all share,
by the globalization of trade,
economies, and education,
and by hope.
Fragmentation stems from
our worst tendencies.
Integration stems from the
best of our shared aspirations.
And today we have
many new opportunities
to apply our skills in
science and engineering
in a way that advances these
shared human aspirations.
I have spoken of the
opportunities before you.
But as has just been said,
with great opportunities
comes great responsibilities.
As you leave MIT,
I hope that you
will take with you more
than just the knowledge
you have gained.
Take with you the
sense of wonder and joy
that drives science and
that science instills in us.
Recognize the
promise that is held
in the exploration of nature
and the quest for new knowledge
and new understanding.
And recognize the value of
the intellectual heritage
on which you build.
But your task is to
shape the future.
This will require more than
the knowledge and skills
that you have gained here.
The philosopher Alfred
North Whitehead once said,
it is the business of the
future to be dangerous.
And so you will need to be more
than smart and knowledgeable.
You will need to be courageous.
You will need to be creative
and compassionate as well.
We expect no less of you, and
indeed, we are counting on you.
I urge you to help us build
a world community that
embraces and values different
cultures and heritage that
respects individuals and
works toward the betterment
of all people.
There is fulfillment
in such service.
In the words of
Albert Schweitzer,
"I don't know what
your destiny will be.
But one thing I know--
the ones among you who
will be really happy
are those who have sought
and found how to serve."
As graduates of MIT, you
are in a unique position
to serve and to lead.
You've acquired an
outstanding education.
It has not been a gift.
You have worked for
it, and worked hard.
Nonetheless, your education
has been a privilege.
Now you have a responsibility
to use your education,
to use it wisely,
and use it well.
Today, we celebrate with joy
your journey to this graduation
ceremony and look forward
with hope and optimism
to your journey into the future.
But as we do so, I would
like to share with you
a brief personal reflection,
because I had an experience
this spring that brought
this issue of fragmentation
versus integration home to
me in a very personal way.
I was invited to give
the commencement address
at the University of Tokyo.
Now, to put this
in perspective, you
need to know that when I
was a young boy growing up
in a small town
in West Virginia,
the United States and Japan
were at war with each other.
We were separated by
cultural, historical,
and political differences
vastly greater
than the geographic
distance that separated us.
At that time, it would have
been inconceivable to me
that I might someday
serve as President of MIT.
And it would have been
even far more inconceivable
that I might someday stand to
address the graduating class
of the University of Tokyo.
Yet there I was,
having crossed a bridge
made possible by the
conviction of leaders
and of ordinary citizens
in both countries
that we had more in common
than we had differences.
And while I was halfway around
the globe from Cambridge,
I was speaking at
a university that
has much in common with MIT--
a commitment to
advance human knowledge
and to work toward a world in
which all people can develop
their talents, economies,
health, security, freedom,
and opportunities.
What better ambition
could there be
for any institution or
individual in our world today?
And now as you embark on the
next stage of your journey,
I offer this charge to
you, the graduates of MIT.
Ponder the unthinkable,
question the status quo,
live in the world as well
as in your own nation, dream
of a better future, but
contribute to the present,
share your talents,
commune with all people,
be steady friends
and bold companions,
address the truly important
issues of your time,
be honest in all that you do.
Take your education your
talent and your energy,
and build a nation and
a world community that
considers knowledge
a gift to be shared,
a healthy planet, a
place to be cherished,
and human dignity
and opportunity
fundamental conditions to
be enjoyed by all people.
Men and women of MIT, I wish
you godspeed and the very
best of good fortune.
[APPLAUSE]
D'ARBELOFF: By virtue of the
authority delegated to them
by the Corporation
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
and upon the recommendation
of the faculty,
President Vest will now
present the following degrees--
Bachelor of Science; Bachelor
of Science, Master of Science;
Bachelor of Science,
Master of Engineering;
and the advanced degrees
for the School of Science
and the Whittaker College of
Health Science and Technology.
Provost Robert Brown will
present the advanced degrees
for the School of
Architecture and Planning,
the School of Engineering,
the School of Humanities, Arts
And Social Sciences, and the
Sloan School of Management.
As they approach the stage,
undergraduate degree recipients
will be greeted
by the Chancellor,
the Dean for
Undergraduate Education,
and the Dean for Student Life.
Graduate degree
recipients will be greeted
by the deans of their schools.
The first graduates
to be recognized
are the class marshals who
are seated on the stage.
PRESENTER 1:
Recognition will now
be given to the offices
of the Class of 2003
and the offices of the
Graduate Student Council,
who are seated on the stage.
Sina K. Nazemi, President
of the Class of 2003,
is awarded the degree
of Bachelor of Science
in Political Science.
Michael R. Hall, Vice
President of the Class of 2003,
is awarded the degree
of Bachelor of Science
in Computer Science
and Engineering.
Suneth Wijesinghe, President of
the Graduate Student Council,
is pursuing the degree
of Doctor of Philosophy.
John P. Locke, Vice President
of the Graduate Student Council,
is pursuing the degree
of Doctor of Philosophy.
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Architecture
and Planning who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Art and Design.
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Architecture and Planning
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Architecture
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
and Architecture Studies.
[READING NAME]
PRESENTER 1:
Bachelor of Science,
as recommended by the
Department of Architecture.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1: Bachelor
of Science in Planning.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Engineering
who have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Civil Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
in Building Technology.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of
Science in Visual Studies.
[READING NAME]
PRESENTER 1: Bachelor of Science
in Environmental Engineering
Science.
[READING NAME]
PRESENTER 2: Master
in City Planning.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1: Bachelor of Science
in Mechanical Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
in Urban Studies and Planning.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
in Media Arts and Sciences.
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of
Science in Media Technology.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
in Real Estate Development.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
without specification of field.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Doctor
of Philosophy,
with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Engineering
who have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Master of Engineering in Civil
and Environmental Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1:
Bachelor of Science,
as recommended by the Department
of Mechanical Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1: Bachelor of
Science in Material Science
and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1:
Bachelor of Science,
as recommended by the
Department of Material Science
and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1: Bachelor
of Science in Archeology
and Materials, as recommended
by the Department of Material
Science and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 1: Bachelor of
Science in Electrical Science
and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
in Civil and Environmental
Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of Science
in Mechanical Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 3: Bachelor of Science
in Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of
Engineering in Materials
Science and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master of
Science in Material Science
and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 2: Master
of Engineering
in Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science
in Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 3: Bachelor of
Science in Computer Science
and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science
in Chemical Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science
in Chemical Engineering
Practice.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Science in Ocean Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Science in Naval Architecture
and Marine Engineering, Naval
Construction and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science
in Ocean Systems Management.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Engineering in Aeronautics
and Astronautics.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Science in Aeronautics
and Astronautics.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science
in Nuclear Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master
of Engineering
in Biomedical Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Engineering in Logistics.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Science in Bioengineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science
in Engineering and Management.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science
in Technology and Policy.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Chemical Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Science in Toxicology.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of
Science in Transportation.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Master of Science,
without specification of field.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 4: Naval
Engineer, Naval Construction
and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 6: Doctor of
Science, with all the rights
and privileges
pertaining thereto.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 6: Doctor
of Philosophy,
with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5:
Bachelor of Science,
as recommended by the Department
of Chemical Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Ocean Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of Science
in Aerospace Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Aerospace Engineering
with Information Technology.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Nuclear Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Humanities,
Arts and Social Sciences
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Economics.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Political Science.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor
of Science in History.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Literature.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor
of Science in Music.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Humanities.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of Science
in Humanities and Engineering.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of
Science in Philosophy.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor of Science
in Linguistics and Philosophy.
[READING NAME]
PRESENTER 6: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Humanities,
Arts and Social Sciences
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Science in
Political Science.
[READING NAME]
PRESENTER 5: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be presented
to students in the Sloan
School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Management Science.
[READING NAME]
PRESENTER 6: Master of Science
in Comparative Media Studies.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 6: Doctor
of Philosophy,
with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 6: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be presented
to students in the Sloan
School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Business
Administration.
Sloan Fellows.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Science who
have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Chemistry.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 6: Master of
Science in Management.
Sloan Fellows.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 8: Master of
Business Administration.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor
of Science in Biology.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor of
Science, as recommended
by the Department of Biology.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor
of Science in Physics.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor of
Science in Brain and Cognitive
Sciences.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor of
Science in Earth Atmospheric
and Planetary Sciences.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor of
Science in Mathematics.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Bachelor of
Science in Mathematics
with Computer Science.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Science who
have completed the specified
degree requirements.
Master of Science in Chemistry.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Master
of Science in Physics.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Master of
Science in Brain and Cognitive
Sciences.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Master of
Science in Geosystems.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Doctor
of Philosophy,
with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 8: Master of
Science in Management.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: The Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution
and the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology offer
joint programs of education
and research in Oceanography
and Applied Ocean
Science and Engineering.
John W. Farrington, Vice
President of Academic Programs
and Dean at the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution,
is here to participate
with President Vest
in awarding the
following joint degrees.
Electrical Engineer.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Doctor
of Philosophy,
with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be presented to
students in the Whittaker
College of Health
Sciences and Technology
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Science in
Medical Informatics.
[READING NAME]
PRESENTER 8: Master of Science
in Management of Technology.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 7: Doctor
of Philosophy,
with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto.
PRESENTERS: [READING NAMES]
PRESENTER 8: Master of Science
in Operations Research.
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy, with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto.
[READING NAMES]
[APPLAUSE]
D'ARBELOFF: It is
now my pleasure
to introduce James A. Lash,
the Chief Marshal, who
will greet the graduates.
Mr. Lash a member
of the Class of 1966
and is currently serving as the
President of the Association
of Alumni and Alumnae of MIT.
LASH: Please join me and
the distinguished members
of the 50th reunion
Class of 1953
as we congratulate the
graduates and welcome them
into that most select
company of men and women
who are the MIT
alumnae and alumni.
[APPLAUSE]
D'ARBELOFF: The 137th
commencement exercises
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
are now concluded.
[CHEERING]
A reception will now
follow in the West Campus
Plaza and the Johnson
Athletic Center.
The audience and
graduates are requested
to remain seated until the
stage assembly has recessed.
And now please join
the MIT Chorallaries
in singing the school song.
It's on page five in the
front section of your program.
Please rise.
[MUSIC - "ARISE YE SONS OF MIT"]
CHORALLARIES: (SINGING)
Arise all ye of MIT,
in loyal fellowship.
The future beckons unto ye,
and life is full and rich.
Arise and raise
your glass on high.
Tonight shall ever
be a memory that
will never die for ye of MIT.
Thy sons and daughters, MIT,
return from far and wide
and gather here once more to
be renourished by thy side.
And as we raise our glasses high
to pledge our love for thee,
we join all those of days
gone by in praise of MIT.
[MUSIC - "TAKE ME BACK TO TECH"]
Oh, I wish that
I were back again
at Tech on Boylston Street,
dressed in my dinky uniform, so
dapper and so neat.
I'm crazy after calculus,
I never had enough.
'Twas hard to be
dragged away so young.
It was horribly, awfully tough.
Hurrah for Technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh!
Glorious old Technology,
All Back in the days
that were free from care
in the 'ology varsity shop, with
nothing to do but analyze air
in an anemometrical top.
The differentiation of
the trigonometric powers,
the constant pi
that made me sigh
in those happy days of ours.
Hurrah for Technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh!
Glorious old Technology,
Take me back on a special train
to that glorious institute.
I yearn for the inspiration
of a technological toot.
I'd shun the quizzical
physical profs, the chapel,
and all that.
But how I'd love to go
again on a scientific bat.
La, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la--
doot-doo-doo-doo, doot-doo,
duh-dah, duh-dah, duh-dah.
O, M-A-S-S-A-C-H-U-S-E-T-T-S,
I-N-S-T-I-T-U-T-E O-F-T-E,
and then there's C-H-N-O-L-O-G
and Y comes after G.
It's the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Hey!
[CHEERING]
[PROCESSIONAL MUSIC]